(bright ambient music)
You never know who's watching,
who you're going to or who you can impact.
It becomes you're not showing up for me,
I'm showing up for the other people.
(bright ambient music)
Do the work today, do everything you can,
allow the team to take care of you
and then let's face tomorrow when tomorrow comes.
Hey, everybody, welcome to the podcast.
My name is Rich Roll
and as some of you guys know among other things,
I am an endurance athlete known for doing some crazy stuff,
like double iron distance triathlons,
and that time I did five iron distance triathlons
on five Hawaiian islands in under a week.
Well, James Lawrence, a.k.a the Iron Cowboy
makes all of that just sounds, I don't know, cute.
This guy recently completed what I think is one of,
if not the most astonishing achievements
in the history of voluntary human endurance
by completing 101 consecutive iron distance triathlons
in 101 days.
In other words, for context, every day,
without missing a single day for 101 days in a row,
this guy climbed out of bed, swam 2.4 miles,
rode his bike 112 miles,
and then completed a marathon 26.2 miles on foot.
Now, as somebody who has a bit of experience
with this type of thing,
even I have a hard time comprehending it,
even though I twice traveled to his neck of the woods
in Lindon, Utah, both for day 91 and day 100
to really just get a glimpse of it for myself.
Well, as you might've guessed, he's here today.
He's joined by his amazing wife,
his better half and team captain Sunny Jo,
to help all of us make sense of this crazy affair.
In addition to just breaking down the enormity of this feed,
this I think is a really powerful conversation
that just might forever change your perspective
on human potential.
It's also a masterclass on mental toughness
where it comes from, how to develop it
and the power we all possess to endure the unimaginable
as well as the critical role that teamwork,
community building and service play
in accomplishing audacious goals,
as well as how presence and mindfulness really hold the key
to achieving the impossible.
So without further ado, please hit that subscribe button
kindly tag that notification bell, and let's do the thing.
Good to see you guys, thanks for doing this.
Yeah buddy.
Last time I saw you,
you were in a different state of mind.
That was a Vendetta.
I'm not gonna say I remember much.
You look a little bit better now.
Yeah, thanks.
I guess the first thing is, how are you doing?
Like, how are you recovering?
How's the body doing?
How's the mental state?
I know it's been a bit of a battle.
Yeah it's been a journey for sure, yeah.
Very different than coming off the 50,
coming off the 100.
I mean, this is what they warned me about,
coming off the 50 was, hey, there's gonna be a let down,
there's gonna be some depression,
there's gonna be some whatever.
And coming off the 50, it was just like this whirlwind
right into what was next.
And this one, we're more established,
I was already doing what I was gonna be doing
coming out of the 100.
And so, and you take a seven week adventure
and turn it into a 14 week adventure,
which is a quarter of a year,
that impact on the mind and the body is significant.
And I had no idea
the level of which my world was gonna get rocked.
We told him, he didn't listen.
Yeah.
Well, you told him
after the 50 and it didn't happen, right?
So he got all cocky about it.
Yeah, yeah.
I did, yeah, I did.
Really, he did.
I was like-
He really did.
Well, it's funny and I've said this before,
but I had someone asked me on day 98, could I do 200?
I think somebody asked me that
on the therapy table, didn't they?
One night, like close to the end,
could you do another 100?
Yeah.
And I was like immediate,
oh absolutely 100%, let's keep going.
You were just in the groove.
But then day 102 I was like,
how did we get to this point?
How did we even do that?
And so it was very apparent and very amazing to me
the power that the mind has
and what it was protecting me from.
But the team could see it
from the outside looking in, right?
Because I was on...
When we do these things we're on very different journeys,
same storyline, different journeys, right?
Same timeframe, different journeys.
And you don't go from like, oh day 60 to 61,
you go from things are normal to I'm in a protective state.
You slowly slip into that
and you don't realize you're transitioning.
Right, like your brain is compartmentalizing everything
and just trying to keep you alive,
so your blinders have you just focused on the task at hand
and everything else is obliterated.
And my team that intimately knows me, meaning my wife,
she could see a slow change, but then she knows,
okay, this is not normal to her.
Was there a moment Sunny where it tipped
and you're like we're in a danger zone situation here?
Were you ever-
No.
Concerned beyond the normal?
I've been married to James way too long for that,
I disregard any worryings.
I think the thing that was most challenging was
the mood swings.
So on the 50, he was completely non-coherent,
there was no one home.
And it was like we were guiding this zombie
through this journey,
where this time around, he had a little bit of his mind,
but thought he had more of his mind than he did.
And so there were some issues with him
trying to make executive decisions
or doing things that he had no business doing,
thinking his mind was right,
but then the moods were all over the place.
And so for me, I mean, we've been married 20 years,
I know exactly what type of person he is,
how he behaves in a certain circumstances and whatnot.
So to see these different moods
and these different personalities come out,
I was like, wow, he is in a really bad place
because we've been married 20 years
and I've never seen this person.
And so I had to check myself
and make sure that I didn't internalize any of that,
and just say, I got to get him through this.
And there were things I wanted to say in the moment
that I had to check myself and say,
but this is what I need to say,
and this is how I have to work him through this.
So that was quite complex.
And frankly, I don't think anybody had the skills
to do other than me.
Yeah, well, being the team captain, you had so many jobs.
I think people don't really appreciate
the amount of effort and intentionality and just the extent
to which this commandeered your entire life
and your family's life, this was a family journey,
but you being kind of captain of this ship,
part of that responsibility is
given that you know James so well,
knowing when it might be appropriate to pull him aside
and pull the plug on this thing, right?
Definitely, definitely.
If it's really going south.
And at the same time masking the severity
of the situation to James or towards James,
to make sure that he doesn't get discouraged
because I'm the ultimate optimist
and I'm the ultimate problem solver.
So if I showed any signs of weakness
or concern towards James,
it would have completely demoralized him.
So I had to maneuver and manage
the severity of certain situations behind his back
without him seeing it or knowing it
to make sure that it didn't demoralize him
in this journey.
Right.
That's a very complex things,
especially where I'm a very forthright person.
I'm not wanting to just be like, everything's okay,
I'm very forthright.
And so it was a delicate balance
of saying what has to be addressed, what not.
And at the same time,
James didn't listen to anything we said anyway, so.
(laughing)
If I said, this is really serious, you're gonna die today,
he'd be like, that's great, I've got things to do.
So it was quite an interesting balance.
Yeah.
I was never gonna die though.
No, he was never gonna die.
No.
But I mean, when I think about the difference
between the 100 versus the 50, 50, 50,
as mind-blowing as the 50, 50, 50 was,
a big portion of that was logistics
and managing chaos and all the crazy variables
that are baked into going from state to state to state,
and the difference with the 100
despite the fact that it's twice the distance,
is that you could implement systems
and minimize the amount chaos
to create some level of predictability.
I mean, obviously
when you're doing 100 iron distance triathlons,
there's gonna be stuff that happens
that you're not gonna foresee,
and we're gonna get into that.
But I'm interested in your expectations
for how it would go versus how it unfolded,
because you thought like, okay, well I'm at home,
I'm gonna sleep in my bed every night.
I've got this team around me, we have a home base,
I'm gonna go out and do this one thing
and it's essentially gonna be the same every single day.
Yeah.
Let me say
this one thing first.
Before we started, I said,
I'm gonna sit down with the wingman,
James, you're not invited,
we're gonna have a conversation about
some of the things that went wrong on the 50
and how he can change him,
and all of them were tied to logistics.
So going in, we were like,
we don't even know what to worry about
because everything from the 50
that was complex had to do with logistics.
Yeah, and that was the whole premise
going into the 100 was,
okay, if the 50 truly was chaos logistics,
if we remove that, can we double what we did?
And because the original goal going into the 50
was how many consecutive can I do,
what's my limit mentally and physically.
And we said on the 50, 'cause it was a cool project,
we threw in the logistics and that became
the kind of centerpiece of the project.
And so with years removed from the project
and having an opportunity to now...
COVID happens, my calendar gets wiped clean,
having an opportunity to plan.
You were on
the speaking circuit,
basically traveling all over the place.
Speaking, coaching and racing,
all three of those things got shut down in 48 hours.
And so I basically had a year
to start to prepare and get ready.
And we were initially gonna do the project
in the fall, like right now,
and I just kept getting the impression March 1st,
do it March 1st, start in March 1st.
And a lot of times with like gut or intuition,
we don't know why in the moment,
and a lot of people will not follow it
'cause it's not logical or it doesn't make sense.
And Sunny and just talked, we've talked about it,
and she was like, well, if you keep getting the impression,
we've got to do it in March.
And now looking back on it,
there's a lot of reasons why March made way more sense
than it did now.
But the problem that it created was
it up the timetable six months,
and physically, that's a big difference
when you're preparing for this,
when you have over the past five years,
removed from the 50 become out of shape and not ready
and I was really relying on past experience.
And I also knew that,
okay, this project is a quarter of a year
and I'm gonna use the 100,
the first half of it as training, for the back half.
Well, you just can't anticipate the toll that
that amount of volume is gonna do to your body.
And right out of the gate,
I just got riddled with injuries and problematics
and it was just like, now we've got to solve these problems.
Right, right.
'Cause we decided October,
so that left November, December, January, February,
we had four months with it.
Yeah, and you didn't do a ton of running
getting ready for it, right?
I did almost no running.
Wow.
None, and if it was,
like 12 minute mile on a treadmill, if it was.
So I was running max three days a week.
And the reason for that was what?
I say two, he says three, two.
Maybe it was two.
What was the reason for that?
Did you have some injuries
that you were dealing with with that or?
So I did have an ankle injury that I didn't vocalize,
but I wasn't concerned about it
because my body's great at adapting and evolving,
just from a decade worth of experience.
But for me, the running is the hardest on my body
and always leads to...
With any athletes that I coach,
running is the biggest contributor to injury.
And so I was like, okay, if I can become super strong,
super strong, powerful on the bike,
I'm not gonna be running fast,
my body will adapt and evolve in the first part of it.
Well to go from running, okay two days a week
(Sunny laughing)
Right.
To, what's the quick math?
26 times seven, 140 miles a week, that's-
Yeah, not a lot of wisdom in that.
Yeah, that's the quickest way to get injured.
That's his mind though.
He doesn't think, oh, I'm gonna go from this to this,
he says, I have this idea and I'm going to do it, right?
He doesn't-
I just remember,
in the early, I don't know,
all the days kind of blur together,
but it was definitely early in the conquest
where things were going sideways.
And your mantra was, this is the process,
like this is the adaptation period.
And it just looked like everything was completely unraveling
and you were hobbling and just was not.
And you're like, we just have to get through this phase
until the body adapts,
and I was like, good luck with that, man.
We couldn't believe it like.
(laughing)
It went sideways so fast and so early.
Like so early, like not even a week,
not even a week.
Like not even a week.
Not even a week and I'm in a lot of pain
and I'm in a lot of trouble,
but our team just doesn't quit
and that's the interesting part
and we don't quit on each other.
And so nobody was like,
hey, we should probably dial this backwards,
we're just like, okay.
Your ankle was like three times the size of normal.
I wanna find that picture
when I'm sitting on the fireplace mantle
and it is just like, you can't tell the difference
between my quad and my ankle.
Well and part of why I'm laughing so hard
is because on the 50,
I remember six days in he's miserable
and I'm like, oh, he'll adapt like at day 10,
and day 10 comes and I'm like, oh, he'll adapt like day 15.
And we're like to day 30 and I'm just saying,
oh yeah, his body's gonna adapt, it's gonna adapt.
I just kept waiting.
By the time we were at like 85
and we're like, why are we still dealing with foot problems
and blisters.
Seriously.
Maybe it's 'cause you're getting up every day
and doing an iron distance triathlon
and not giving your body the ability to adapt.
Why are we so positive?
I mean we were such fools.
I just remember Sunny saying multiple times,
like with 20 to go every single,
like, why are we still dealing with this problem?
Why is this still a problem?
Like we're 80 days into this,
we should have overcome this by...
And if I was to contrast the two, the 50 and the 100,
the 50 was chaos, logistics and fatigue,
this one was injuries, pain and longevity,
and it just never let up, and so...
They had nothing in common.
They were two very different projects.
On the surface, you're like, oh, consecutive, consecutive,
very, very, very different, excuse me, projects.
And we were dealing with very different things
on both of them
and we were in very different times of our lives too.
I mean, we're talking six months removed,
I mean, six years removed from that accomplishment.
And that was the biggest thing too,
is like leading into the 50,
we're talking a consistent decade worth
of projects leading up to it, stepping stones, growth,
and then right into the next one.
Well then you pause for six years
because you're providing for the family,
you're speaking, you're coaching, you're mentoring,
you're doing all these things.
And then you're like,
oh, let's just pick up right where we left off,
double it and try to-
That's how James thinks.
That's how he thinks and I'm like sweetheart.
What was the original impetus for the idea?
Like was it because everything closed down
or was it already something that you were planning on doing
at some point?
No, I hadn't...
After the 50 I was done, like it was over.
I was satisfied, it was good.
And,
we were just so busy,
we were so busy with everything
there wasn't an opportunity to do what's next,
but I'd be lying if I didn't say I was always intrigued
with what's possible, is there more-
Once you had time to reflect.
Once I had time to reflect.
But there really wasn't an opportunity
because even if I wanted to carve it out,
like we were booking our speaking well in advance
and for me, we live a great life now
and I was like, okay, I don't have to shut this down
for a year in order to do something right.
Would that be the responsible thing
as the head of the household.
And now I've got teenagers, I got four daughters
that means four weddings,
kids are starting to go to university.
I don't know, I'm looking at the cost of this
and I'm like, I don't have the luxury
to not to stop doing this over here
to try to push my limits even further.
And the pandemic really forced my hand
for lack of a better phrase,
but just really put the opportunity on the table
because literally 48 hours
my entire calendar got wiped clean.
Every event counseled, my bureau called me, they're like,
hey, we just had the entire year's worth of events canceled.
Your month of March was, I mean, minute to minute,
he had six weekends in a row of racing, it was packed.
So not only was it wiped clean, but it was like...
I was inconsolable 'cause I was like, oh my gosh,
this is gonna be an intense six weeks and then gone.
Yeah, but I love the perspective shift.
I mean, you can kind of wallow in misery
and self-pity over that
or you can use the pause to figure out how to level up.
And one of the things
that I didn't realize about the 50
was the extent to which you guys were going through
a very difficult kind of financial time with that.
I mean, I've gone through something similar to that
and using the 50 as a way, like, well, here's what I can do,
like things are not working out
and we're having trouble making ends meet,
but I can do this one thing.
And there's kind of a big faith piece there
that if I do this,
somehow the universe will conspire to support me
in a new and unique way.
Yeah, oh for sure.
Beautifully said.
And
you always get asked, what's your why,
what's your purpose, what's your reason for doing something?
And people always ask too, well, why didn't you quit
or how do you keep going?
And on the 50, like our reasons were so strong,
like it was get our lives back,
change the direction of our lives
and quitting wasn't on the table.
And then to contrast that to the 100
and the reasons why you're doing it
are very, very different.
Like we're established in our career,
like it was a huge dice role for me to double it
because now I'm risking the criticism
that we took on the 50.
Like you don't make it past 50
so that really rings true on
when you just said on week one things start to go sideways
and you're like, I'm risking my entire career
and decades worth of work for this new project
that I don't have to do,
because now the reasons that I was doing the 50
are very different than they are doing now.
And this, the 100 was truly,
what am I capable of mentally and physically?
Because career-wise, there wasn't a huge uptake,
there wasn't a huge, like, benefit to doing it.
I was already established in my speaking career,
we've already got the book, the documentary,
everything's going great.
And so it was really like, well, why are you doing this?
Like what's the risk reward to what you're doing?
What's the answer to that?
Why did I do it?
It was for me, it was personal.
That's the answer
Yeah, absolutely.
It was redemption.
I believe a part of it was redemption for me.
Well, you had told me that part of it was motivated
by sort of silencing the critics
'cause there was a little bit of mumbling about the 50,
'cause of circumstances, et cetera, a bunch of nonsense.
Yeah.
So it was about
putting that to rest.
There was definitely a huge part of that
for me personally,
and a big part of my platform is like,
look, don't listen to the grumblings, the haters,
don't give them any power
and at the same time, I was like-
They're eating me alive.
They're eating me alive
and do you flip that coin and say,
well, is there a little bit of reason
to what they're saying and are they?
And you really have to have that.
That's a hard conversation to have with yourself,
like balancing and reckoning those thoughts
and okay, is what they're saying, truth
and is there some validity to it?
And over the course of five years in speaking on stages,
you get off of stage and you post something that you did.
And it's just one person says something online
and you're like, well, am I a hypocrite?
Did I really do what I said I did?
Am I presenting what I truly believe?
And then I had this opportunity when the 2020 hit,
I have an opportunity to reset history.
And when we were on the course of the 100,
man, day 51 was huge for me.
Well, I even had little landmarks too, right?
So make it past 18 when you crashed your bike,
fell asleep and crashed on your bike,
make it past day 19 when you got on the elliptical, right?
And you make it past that and you're like,
okay, I've reset that piece of my history,
I've reset that piece of my history,
that's no longer on the table.
And then you make your past 50 and now you're 51,
and everyday you wake up,
you got to break a new world record
and then that becomes fun, right?
For me,
this was the tale of two halfs.
There was so much pressure on me personally,
that I put on myself to make it back to 51, right?
Because you don't get the 51
and you personally discredited everything you've done
in the past,
'cause if they didn't think you did it the first time,
you certainly didn't do it the second time if you fail.
And so for me on my journey,
that first 50 was like so important to me.
And I remember having conversations
with Aaron on the bike every single day,
okay, this day means this, this day means this
once we make it past here.
And the back half became everyday,
just like this is who we thought we were
and who we said we were
and I wanna show it to you.
What I hear in sharing that
is this idea of setting an audacious goal,
but the path towards accomplishing
something that is seemingly impossible
is to break it down into these little chunks.
I mean, it's truly about what you're doing in the moment.
And there's a broader conversation
that we can have about being present and the mindfulness
that you have to bring to each moment
and just focusing on what you have to accomplish
and the next day, the next hour or whatever it is,
but having those little benchmarks
and then allowing yourself to celebrate them
is the fuel that keeps you engaged
with something that otherwise it's just too overwhelming
to even process.
Well, two different things.
One, that moment happened early on,
like when you said looking from the outside,
looking in that things went sideways
it was probably about day 15
when my shin was at the peak of its pain,
the first shin problem was at the peak of its pain.
And literally every step I took,
I thought I was gonna break my leg
and I just continued to manage it.
And I remember finishing one day,
it was probably around 15
and I said to Sunny that night, I said,
"Hey, I don't think I can manage that level of pain
for 85 more days, something has to give."
And full knowing that something maybe wasn't gonna give,
Sunny just said, hey, look...
And this is the best advice I got on the entire 100.
She said, hey, the work is done today.
Do you remember this one?
Of course, I do.
Okay.
It happened more than once.
She said, I remember the one, but she's-
You've opened the truth box.
'Cause I was like, hey...
I would kind of just shrug my shoulders
and just complete-
Totally demoralized.
I was totally demoralized,
totally dejected because I was the one
that was managing the pain,
and I couldn't like voice
how much I was dealing with, and-
I don't think you could even conceive it
because your mind wasn't even...
I mean, there were so much dissonance
in the mind and the body.
Right.
And so I remember saying,
I can't manage that level of pain for 85 more days
'cause I knew what that took,
and she said, you don't have to, the work is done today.
And I was like, "what?"
She's like just trust in your team,
let us take care of you tonight, you're done today.
It was in the shower, I said you're in a hot shower
'cause it was freezing, right?
It was cold too.
It like you're in a hot shower,
right now you're in a hot shower.
And she said, we have no idea
what tomorrow is gonna bring.
You could feel totally different tomorrow,
and I felt like crap the next day, but we did turn corners.
And that became for me,
the mantra of the entire campaign was,
do the work today, do everything you can,
allow the team to take care of you
and then let's face tomorrow when tomorrow comes.
And then for me, deeper into the campaign,
back to what we were just talking about,
about how we had those benchmarks
and the first half was really me resetting history
or my history.
Slowtwitch has been one of the biggest haters of me.
Slowtwitch Forum is not a friendly place.
It's not a friendly place.
And I mean, they were ruthless towards me
and I've actually had the honor
of Slowtwitch reach out to me recently
and wants to sit down, which I'll do.
Herbert, yeah.
Yeah, which I'll do.
But there was a point in the 100 where Aaron had gone on...
Aaron's one of the wing men
and he had gone on to Slowtwitch and he said,
'Hey, they have just started a forum that says,
James has done it,
and this thread is nothing but positivity about it."
And in that moment, when Aaron came and said that,
I was like, I frigging turned Slowtwitch.
How many days in, where are you at, at this point?
Oh, well past halfway.
Yeah, yeah.
So it took that long
before you could shift that titanic around.
Yeah, but for me,
that was like the last like thing
for me to reset my history.
Last thing unfinished.
Unfinished business, for me it was like,
hey, Slowtwitch has started a positive forum about you,
and I'm like, wow, that's amazing.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
So that was kinda my moments.
That's no small thing
for anybody's familiar with that ecosystem.
Exactly, and so those kinds of two moments
for me were really pivotal,
that conversation with Sunny early, early on
where I was completely broken,
couldn't conceptualize 85 more
and then fast forward all the way
to where we'd reset history,
we made it past all of those personal benchmarks of mine.
And then Slowtwitch starts a positive only forum
about the Iron Cowboy who has been their biggest target
for years and years and years.
So obviously Sunny, this is a family decision.
So did James come to you with this idea?
Did you concoct this together?
Like what does that look like as a family with five kids
when 14 weeks are gonna be monopolized by this endeavor
and it's gonna take everything that all of you guys have?
And you've got kids who are living their own lives
and need attention and care, like how does all of that work?
'Cause if there is a sliver of criticism,
where it's like, oh, this is selfish
and they're shirking their responsibilities
with their kids and all of that.
And like, as somebody who knows you guys
and visited twice during this event
and bore witness to what was going on,
like this was a family adventure completely,
like all your kids are in.
I mean, Lucy, I mean, forget about it,
we could do a whole podcast
on how amazing she was throughout this whole thing.
But what did that look like as a family decision
and as a family affair?
We had conversed
and researched some other projects.
So a couple of years after the 50,
James was like I kind of have some ideas
and so we kind of researched some ideas
and none of them were really working out.
There was a lot of pressure from sponsors
and biggest question,
what's next, what's next, what's next?
And he's a dreamer, so his mind is always brewing.
So we thought about all these different ideas
and they weren't really working
and James has a lot of ideas,
you guys only see what happens.
So as we kind of went
through this ideas
Like you're gonna box
Jake Paul or something.
Sure, why not?
Let's go.
Where's Mcgregory, where are you?
Where's my hundred million for the bike?
I'm due for a payday, Rich.
So we had kind of explored these different ideas,
but I hadn't gotten all caught up in them
because there's so much complexity to preparing them
that my mind was open to ideas,
but I wasn't necessarily concerned about the investment yet.
And then as they continued to fall through
and oh, these aren't gonna work the way we thought it would.
He said to me one day early in that year, maybe May,
he's like, I just keep thinking about doing 100 folds,
and I was like really?
Because he'd kind of not been soured
but had been turned off by the 50,
just because it had been so intense that I was surprised
that he was going to consider something
in that same type of realm, but even harder.
So I was like, oh, that's interesting.
And then a week later comes back he's like,
no, I really can't stop thinking about it.
So we kind of talked about it for a couple of weeks
and finally I said, if you can't stop thinking about it,
that's God telling you to do it, which makes no sense.
I mean,
everything James has ever done in his life makes no sense,
including sitting on a Ferris wheel for 10 days.
There's no logic to James' goals and dreams and aspirations.
So he's like, I'm going to kind of dangle a carrot,
talk to some sponsors, kind of feel it out,
do a little research
and see how I can maybe make this work out.
And how it would be received.
Yeah, how it will be received,
how much support I could get,
if it really is something that could work.
And so in August he said,
"Hey, it's gonna work, everybody's in."
And when you realize how long it is, then you're saying,
okay, my gosh, how are we gonna fit this
into a four season year?
In Utah we got four seasons.
So he said, I'm either gonna catch an early snow
or I'm going to catch...
I mean, a late snow in the spring
or an early snow in the fall.
And so we are less likely to have an early snow in the fall,
and if you do, it's just gonna be a one day thing and melt.
So we had kind of established the idea
of starting in August, doing August, September, October.
In Utah, we have a lot of sunshine in the winters
and we don't get snow till the later in the year,
so we're like this is gonna be great.
And then he comes to me and says,
"Hey, I keep feeling like we should do this in March."
I was like, March?
He's like, "yeah, March 1st."
I'm like, really?
So I kind of sat on it for a couple of days.
And then I looked at my calendar
and I was like, you can't do it March.
I mean, I had the entire spring planned out
from my 40th birthday to spring break
to all of these things in this calendar.
And I was like, James, if you do this in March,
it's gonna complete disrupt my year.
It quickly came, don't talk to me about this
until after Thanksgiving and after Christmas
then I'll process it.
Yeah, like, so I said, he's like, okay
and then he kind of came back again
and he's like, I just feel like we should do it March,
and I was like, oh my gosh,
right now in this moment, I hate you for this.
Because James is a person of conviction
and he's not going to come to me and say,
I think we should do this
unless he actually thinks we should do it.
He's not bluffing on stuff like that,
that's just not his personality.
If he's passionate about something, there's something to it.
So I was like, I hate you right now
because I know this must be the right thing to do,
but it's going to ruin my life.
So this was like in November,
our anniversary is at the beginning of December and...
Our 20th.
He's like putting in little blurps, like this and that,
and I was like, I don't even wanna talk about it.
Like I have to process this,
this is really going to mess my year up.
And so our anniversary came,
we obviously stressed out our mind playing at the 100.
I said, we got to do something, it's our 20th.
We always travel, but obviously last year was different
with COVID and everything.
So we just did a staycation in Park City
and we got to dinner
and he's like, I can't do this without your support.
So you're telling me we can do it,
but I know the support's not there,
I know you have your own conviction or whatever.
And so I was like,
you just need to give me time to process this.
I did a lot of praying
and within two weeks I was like, okay, I'm all in.
He's like, you're all in?
Shocked, right?
Oh my gosh, you're all in.
Are you sure, you're all in?
I'm like, I'm all in,
because at that point I had my own conviction.
Like God had told me myself
this was the right thing to do, I knew
and so I just canceled everything.
It was like the year was canceled
because I knew from March to June,
I mean, we had Easter and graduation and birthdays
and I mean, just so many things that I was like,
okay, I'll do the best I can to prepare for these
before we start going so far as to packing Easter eggs
and preparing all the baskets and putting them in my closet,
so that when it came, because with the 50,
there were a lot of promises
of it's gonna be this great adventure,
it's gonna be super easy, blah, blah,
and then it was complete havoc.
So I'm like, I know the idea is that this will be simpler
because we're at home,
but the reality is I know that won't really happen.
So I was trying to plan everything I could
before we started.
But then I knew, I knew it was go time and I knew,
so whenever James would struggle,
I knew it's what we were supposed to be doing,
and so I just always looked for a way through it.
He couldn't do that 'cause his mind wasn't there.
So my job was to be the sound mind to that experience
and to rely on the faith
that I knew it's what we were supposed to be doing
and to seek solutions.
And to be all in, I mean, it was all consuming.
I mean, your house was completely taken over,
this HQ for this thing.
Ground centric.
In my life, it's like everything I've done is gone, right?
That's a huge sacrifice.
It's like
there's no pick a ball.
I hope it's Sunny time now.
I ruined our 20th wedding anniversary
and her 40th birthday.
I mean,
it's the day of atonement, James right now.
But really I wasn't going to try to find balance,
it was not appropriate, the balance would come later.
That 100 days was about this project,
it was about James' project,
I knew I would have my time later.
There was no need for balance,
it was literally just dive in and go for it.
Oh and when she signs off and says, I'm all in,
I immediately panicked
because when she goes all in, it's all in.
It's official.
And then I realized...
Yeah, it's official and I'm like, I only have four months
to get ready for this and I'm nowhere close physically.
And that on March start date?
Oh, it was so early.
I mean, I'm watching this on Instagram
and I'm like, it's snowing every day
and it's freezing.
Day one was at 18 Degrees.
And you keep thinking like,
well, just maybe a couple more days of this
and it'll get nice out
and that winter just extended.
I saw how the heat affected you at the end,
so I understand the logic of that.
Obviously you do better in cold than in heat.
Well, and if you look now the fires
that we're dealing with, like Utah has literally
the worst air quality in the world right now
and this would be the month two
of three months of doing it.
And we will be dealing with the heat
and literally one week after we finished
on June 8th or June 9th,
107 degrees outside pavement temperature was 120.
Wow.
One week after.
Yeah, that would have buried you.
Dude, just would have completely
shut me down.
Well, and the other part was
the family was occupied, right?
So it didn't consume their summer.
So the kids were still in school,
my job was to make sure
they were still living their life
feeling like they could just be themselves
and enjoy this journey
and so they were still in school, they were still working,
they were still doing their normal things
and they just enjoyed the 100.
They jumped in when they wanted to, and they enjoyed it.
Except for Lucy.
So the timing was beautiful.
Yeah, except for that.
I mean this became
a full-time job.
But she wanted that.
She crushed it.
She did, I want to say quickly too, for the listeners
that maybe don't know us is we have five kids,
four daughters, one son,
and during the campaign, they were ages 11 through 18.
And so just for the new listener
who maybe doesn't know who we are-
And then Lucy of course, was the project manager of sorts
and James's assistant and ran all the social media,
that's like her dream job though.
So although her stress level was like to the max,
oh man, that's exactly where she wanted to be.
She ended up getting a job out of this, right?
Like any brand who is watching what was going down.
Well, she got a job offer from Visa as an apprentice
and I was like, no, no, no, no, no, she's mine,
so I've hired her full time, she runs my-
She had a lot of dates that she was asked on
and she had a lot of job offers,
all of which she turned down.
Yeah, jobs and dates.
She's like, why are these people trying to date me online?
She earned it, she was on point the entire time.
It was unbelievable.
Yeah, she was special.
So let's talk a little bit about
some of the obstacles you face.
I mean, you alluded to the shin problem
and the ankle problem early on,
that got ameliorated by this brace,
like this custom kind of carbon fiber thing
that you got at some point that allowed you to offload
some of the pressure on your shin.
Yeah, I think any journey,
especially a longer journey to be successful
and anybody that's been on a journey will say
that there was a little bit of luck involved
and this brace situation was a whole lot of luck or Jesus,
and a bit of both.
It just so happens the number one guy in the country
that makes custom carbon braces for ankle
and shin problems lived off of the trail
that we were running on, like he had just moved there.
And one of the cyclists-
Like in Lindon?
In Lindon.
Wow.
One of the cyclists that joined us
is an orthopedic surgeon
that refers all of his post surgery clients to this outfit.
And so I was on the run one day
and he'd obviously got wind that we were struggling
and my shin was bothering me,
he says, "Hey, have you ever considered
a carbon plated shin brace?"
It's an in sole for your shoe,
the brace just holds it to leg,
but it's a carbon in sole to absorb the shock.
And I said, I don't even know what that is,
so I obviously haven't considered it.
And he goes, let me talk to my guy.
What it is is it's a carbon,
like Sunny just said a carbon plate
that goes on the bottom of your shoe, that they fit custom
and then it's got a bar that goes up the side or the front,
depending on how strong you want it to be,
and then it anchors on the top of your calf.
Essentially that carbon plate and the anchor point
with the bar completely offloads that shin
and allows it to heal.
And I said, well, can people walk in it?
And he goes, people can run in them.
And he goes, the first version we'll put you in
will completely offload it, it's pretty restrictive,
you'll be limited to walking,
but as we see, and if we see progress,
we can get you into a running brace.
And so we started with that one and he would meet me
at each one of those intersections off the trail.
And he's like, do you have any...
Like, he just said, these are normally custom,
but we're gonna give one to you, I've got one
and we'll have to tool it and tweak it as we progress.
And so he'd give it to me, I'd put it on, he goes,
"The goal is to have no touch points on your leg."
And I was like, okay, it's touching here and here
and he would take it and to the back of his van,
and he would machine tool it,
and he would like quickly get to the other intersection
before I got there, and he's like, put this on.
And we did that over the course of 26 miles
and by the end of that day,
we had a brace that was somewhat customed to me,
but it wasn't touching any part of my shin,
relieving all pain and allowing me to progress.
And so then every single day we would go through
and manage the level of pain that I was having
and where this brace was touching.
And we would tweak it and he'd come out on different days
and make sure we were still progressing,
and I ended up being in that brace for three or four weeks.
And then we upgraded to the more flexible one,
which allowed me to run some sections in it,
and it was the thing
that allowed us to continue because, like I said-
And you told me that it was so painful
you literally thought you were gonna snap your leg
and you're willing to snap it.
You're like I'm gonna snap my leg before I quit this thing.
Yeah, it was gonna get to the point where
it was gonna snap and that's what was gonna make-
It would be the only circumstance
that would make you to stop.
It was gonna be the narrative that the public would say,
okay, that is an acceptable rate.
Justified.
That's justified
an acceptable reason to stop.
Anything short of that is, you're a quitter
and I obviously don't want that.
And so that brace saved it
because it'll literally allow that stress fracture to heal
while doing a full marathon every single day,
including the bike miles.
Now, what came with that was the imbalance that it created,
which lightning bolted up into my hip,
which then was the next thing.
And this project became, like I said,
injury and management of injury,
and it was this trickle effect, or what's it called?
One thing leads to another?
Domino effect.
Yeah, like a domino effect of injury,
'cause it started with the ankle, went up into the shin,
we dealt with that and we figured it out, we're like-
Then when I moved up through the body.
And I just remember,
I was like, I have no shin pain today,
and we're like, okay, we're clear, we can go,
and the next day, my hip just exploded,
like stopped me on my tracks.
And I remember my therapist, Hayden,
he was like, can we not get one day
where we're not dealing with something?
And it just became this domino effect
of, I was always dealing with something.
Like the busted up feet was the relief.
It was like, oh, good, today you're just missing
the whole bottom of your foot with skin.
Solely, this is it today.
You're looking at this foot thinking,
how does your foot look like this 85 days in
yet we're celebrating this because this is all it is.
Right, right, right, right.
It's all perspective.
Yeah, yeah.
You told me some crazy stories about the sleep disruption.
Yes.
I mean, that just sounds terrifying.
It was, 'cause outside looking in,
someone says, oh, okay, he's done the 140 miles today,
he can now go rest and recover.
Well, that was the second side of that coin
or that journey, right?
So on the outside looking in you're like,
okay, he's doing the swim,
the bike, the run 2.4, 112, 26.
And then they're like, okay-
The complexities continued.
Okay, he gets to go home and sleep and rest.
Well, no, as soon as I got home,
one, I had to refuel,
two it's two to three hours
of pretty intense therapy on the table.
Yeah, you're on the massage table
trying to eat, fall asleep.
Immediately trying to eat,
falling sleep.
While you're eating
while they're working on body.
Managing problems,
solving problems, the house is chaos,
'cause everybody's there, trying to do stuff.
That's an understatement.
Yeah.
Yeah, and then once everybody leaves
and the therapy's done, it was around 11:00 PM, midnight,
most nights I'd move into my bed,
and then my second wave of like managing things would start.
And the three biggest things that we dealt with was
incredible hot sweats, like we're talking.
Sweating through duvets
and I'm like sweating
like you've never seen, it was wild.
And then that leads to dehydration problems,
and trying to keep yourself hydrated.
Panic attacks.
Panic attacks, night terrors,
which finally went away.
Well, the hyperbaric chamber after a while,
we're like, you can't sleep in there
because you can't just get out, right?
If he's freaking out, we can't get to him,
he can't get out.
It was wild.
And kind of not really just being able
to get a restful night of sleep, right?
Like despite the extraordinary fatigue
and you're laying there on the couch or whatever,
with NormaTec boots on falling asleep,
like you're sweating and having the...
And weren't you doing some sleepwalking too?
There were some stories.
Oh, yeah.
Yeah.
It was great stuff.
(laughing)
The kids have some pretty funny stories.
The kids loved it.
That was the highlight of the 100 for them.
I guess there was one time I went upstairs
to just check on my daughters and I had no idea.
And one time I was wandering outside the house
and Dolly was coming home from something
and she was wondering what I was doing.
And didn't realize it and they were saying,
hey, what were you doing outside last night?
And I was like, I was in my bed last night.
So these crazy stories of kids-
Which he has no history of that.
No recollection of it.
No history of it.
But it's so interesting,
like what is going on physiologically
that would cause that.
I mean, have you talked to anybody?
Like you should hook up with like Matt Walker
and have him figure out like, what was going on with you
or what precipitated like that kind of strange situation.
Yeah, and I don't even know how you quantify it
or like study it now.
Literally, when I go home tomorrow, I go to a brain MRI,
'cause I've been dealing with brain fog
and depression and fatigue
and things like that.
It's still lingering.
Yeah, for sure.
And I have good moments and bad moments
and it depends on how much like mental energy I have
to expend throughout a day right now,
but there'll be a point of the day if I've done a lot,
I'd be like Sunny, I think I need to just like rest
or I need you to drive home.
Right after the fact...
This is my favorite story.
Right after the 50, I was driving down the freeway.
Like at the finish line, leaving the finish line.
Yeah.
Was I just leaving?
Yes, because I stuck with you, everybody left.
We had all this stuff and all these cars
and no one to drive them home.
So James had to drive the van home
from the finish line of the 50
with all the bikes on the back.
Oh, I'm thinking of a different story.
Oh, there more than one.
I get pulled over by the police on the way home
from the 50,
and just had to have an interesting conversation
with the police, but the one I'm talking about
was after the 100,
the 100 was over-
You said after the 50.
I'm sorry, I meant the 100.
He's still got brain fog.
(laughing)
Which time is it?
This fits perfectly
to what we're talking about.
Which story?
I'm driving down the freeway and Sunny looks over to me
and she goes, "Sweetheart, you're going 45 miles an hour."
And I was like, oh, okay, I'll pick it up a little bit.
And he did for five minutes,
and then I was like, sweetheart, now you're going 50
and the speed limit is 70.
I remember saying this is a lot faster
than we were going on my bike.
Right.
But you just slip into these bits of brain fog.
And so right when I get home, I'm super fortunate.
Again, one of the only places in the United States
that does this kind of study
and testing for concussion and-
TBI.
Yeah, yeah.
Post traumatic stuff is in Utah
and they actually put you into an MRI,
they set up all the scans
and then they ask you a series of questions
and it's designed to light up every part of your brain
once they take you through the whole protocol.
And then they can see where blood flow isn't going
and which pathways are blocked and what's going on,
and then they put you through an extensive 30 hour protocol
based on the results that resets
and repatterns your brain turns it back on,
and so this is like super exciting for me.
Like professional, like a lot of football players
will go there from across the country,
NFL players or car accidents, concussion people,
people that are showing like signs of Alzheimer's
and things like that will go
to this cognitive therapy place in Provo.
And I'm just so-
So you haven't been there yet,
you're going to go there?
No, right when I land,
I go from the airport to get those MRI scans
and then based on the results,
we'll start the therapy to kind of like reset my brain.
But when you finished you came down to UCLA,
like shortly after you completed the 100
and had a bunch of tests run.
I mean, what was the upshot of that?
Yeah, so we had kind of a baseline testing done
at UCLA prior to,
and they were mostly looking at like cardiovascular, heart
lungs, things like that, the size of it,
what it does under stress, MRI is that way.
And then they wanted to see,
okay, if you put your body through
what the human body can do with 14,000 miles
and then go and get stress tests done.
Did we create like heart murmurs?
Did we create arrhythmic problems?
Did we create all these things
that we did damage to the body?
And as Sunny and I have known,
the body's an amazing piece of machinery.
We completely stumped the cardiovascular world
and these cardiologists, and they were like,
you're fitter and stronger,
and you've done zero damage to your heart.
And did you like break the record
on the stationary part there?
Yeah, the bike test?
Yeah, we broke the last record.
Just 'cause I became such a solid cyclist.
You do 100.
And then after a couple of weeks of break,
you got back on the bike
and we're crushing some KOMS around.
Yes, I PRd around our neighborhood
and some of the climbs that we do,
and for me, getting out was more mental than anything,
just because sitting at home and focusing on the fatigue
and I'm tired and I'm depressed and all that,
that just magnifies the problem.
And so for me, getting out...
I mean the cycling community
really came out on the 100,
and so I had developed a lot of really great friendships.
We'd sit on the bike for six, seven hours a day
and just talk to these new people.
The community really came out and said,
this is our project too, we're protecting you,
we're gonna get you through this.
And then a lot of the cyclists
went through the same thing I did.
They would come out two, three times a week
for a quarter of a year
and then overnight that goes away
and they're like, well, where's our group rides,
and where's that comradery, and where is...?
We've missed that.
And so for me getting back out, it was great for me,
it was great for the community,
it was great for those people
that had their journey alongside our journey.
A lot of people are struggling.
I mean, COVID happened and the world shut down
and a lot of depression and anxiety happened
and Utah happened to be one of the states
from the outside looking in,
we're like we had still an opportunity to go outside
and do stuff and it was really great.
And a lot of those people before...
We just come out of winter
and so people have been trapped inside
and COVID and no families,
and a lot of people lost jobs.
And so this was a project
where it kind of like gave a lot of people, hope and purpose
alongside of what we were doing
and that was special.
This is the real story behind the story.
There's a lot of focus on how did you do the 100
and like the particulars of that
and the family journey that entailed,
but truly it's the community piece.
Absolutely.
And it was so impactful
to visit and see, not only your town come out and support,
I mean, it was like such a beautiful expression
of solidarity.
All these people who were just there for you guys
in every which way.
And then on top of that,
all these people who flew in or drove in
from all parts of the country, all parts of the world.
I met people from Eastern Europe
who flew out to have this experience,
to share this experience with you,
people who are inspired by what you were doing
and what you were sharing online
and just so many lives transformed.
And I think that gets to this piece about
finding the blessings and the misfortunes,
like the fact that you were compelled to walk
actually made it more accessible for a lot of people,
and I think brought a larger contingent of people out.
That was a tremendous blessing.
Yeah, yeah, yeah and became something
that people could wrap their heads around,
like joining you for a long walk
every single day.
That part of it
was so beautiful.
Yeah.
That part of it.
Yeah, I can't tell you
how many times every single day,
one Casey would do kind of a roll count
on who's here, where are you from?
And Casey case he did a great job
at like including everybody talking,
'cause a lot of days, I wasn't in a good headspace to do it
and I'm really focused on what I was doing.
I mean, I spent a lot of time talking to those guys,
like their job is to protect you, like keep you.
'Cause you're gonna get some wacky people too,
who are vying for your attention
and their job is to like make sure
that there's a buffer around you so that you...
Yeah, you can say hello,
but like you got to focus on what you're trying to do.
And the amazing part was
Casey would do the roll call every single day
and then we'd start to hear about other people's stories
and one where they came from but then throughout the day,
that was one of the coolest things for me to experience was,
people did give me my distance
and respect what I was going through.
And yeah, just respected that
but what was a lot of fun was for five, six hours
on the walk around, you could hear the chatter
and the people talking and sharing their stories
in the subgroups,
and just people that would have never crossed paths before.
And every single day without fail,
we had somebody say, or we heard,
hey, we wouldn't have been able to participate in this,
we wouldn't have been able to experience this,
had James been running.
And it was just one of the coolest things that happened
was one, you said community, community was huge.
But two, my pain and suffering and injury became a blessing
to so many other people
that badly wanted to be part of what we were doing,
but otherwise wouldn't have had an opportunity to do so.
And we were just talking at lunch
about this five-year-old kid who had just turned six.
Do you know this story?
I don't know.
Jace, little Jace.
Oh, I do, yeah, but tell us, of course.
So yeah. it's a really cool story.
And this kid says, he was a neighbor of Casey's
and the dad said, okay, we'll go out
because the kid really wanted to do
is part of the walk with us.
And people don't realize,
we were walking at a pretty decent pace.
And if we did take a criticism from the elites,
it was that we were walking and-
I had to run, I couldn't walk that fast
even when I jogged.
It was like brisk walk.
We were walking at a pretty good clip
and we blew a lot of people.
I was falling off the back a couple of times
and I'm like he's moving pretty good,
like I gotta start running here to catch back up.
And so there's this little kid just got inspired
and motivated and said,
I wanna go do a couple miles with the Iron Cowboy.
And the dad was like, okay, we'll get your shoes,
we'll get your shorts on, we'll go out, we'll pick our day.
And he did, he knocked out three miles with us
and then his dad's like, okay, we're done, we did the 5k.
And he's like, no, the Iron Cowboy is still going,
I wanna keep going with him.
And you could see him as we started to progress
and do more miles, he really started to struggle
but this kid had zero quit in him.
Just balling, he was just balling.
He was starting to cry.
He was in so much pain.
He was just in so much pain,
he ended out knocking out 20 miles that night.
It's crazy.
20 miles.
And he had to jog
'cause he's just a little leg, right?
If you think of a five-year-old kid, right?
Off the couch, dude, knocks out 20 miles
and then was just so upset.
His dad ended up telling us that he was so upset
that he wasn't able to finish with us
because he just couldn't go any further.
And so they plotted out another day and he started before us
while we were still on the bike
and he knocked out five or six or seven miles,
and then we eventually caught him
and he stayed with us the rest of the time.
And this five, six year old kid ended up doing
a full marathon with us,
and it was just one of the most unbelievable experiences.
And we were with someone at lunch and they had just said,
he hadn't been taught yet to quit
and it wasn't part of his culture.
And so like, it begs the question,
like when in our adult journey is that a taught thing?
When did it become acceptable?
When did that be part of our culture?
'Cause that kid was just like, no, I'm in a lot of pain,
but I want to do this and I'm going to endure
until I finish.
I'm telling you,
he was balling.
The last three rounds, just crying
and just kept going, it was amazing.
And crying with a smile on his face
and just push and pushing through,
was really, really special.
And for his father
to allow him.
You know a lot of parents are swinging in
and rescuing this kid and Sean, let him.
Sean let him fight through those tears,
Sean, let him finish.
Like that's as beautiful of a story as it is
that Jace get it done.
Yeah and his sense of personal possibility now
is very different than it was before that.
But that's just why, I mean, he's the youngest,
but there were so many people who showed up
who had never done anything before
or were coming off of crazy weight loss stories
and all kinds of stuff.
There's a lot of first marathons.
Yeah, I think the power in what you were doing
was that it normalize something
that seems impossible to most people,
and just to see you doing it day after day after day
and the walking piece made it accessible to people.
And so they're like, well, maybe I'll show up
and I'll do a little bit
and then they end up doing a little bit longer
than they thought they would.
And then before, oh, I'll come tomorrow and...
And then they're doing like the whole marathon,
and there are people who are doing the full iron man?
17, 18 folds.
Yeah like people
who would never sign up for an official iron man showing up
and doing the full thing
because they see you doing it every single day,
and suddenly it seems maybe not as hard
as they thought it might be.
We just sent out hundreds of shirts
because what we said to people is like we said,
hey, come join us,
and if you do, all swim, all bike, all run with us,
when this is over, we'll send everybody
that finished a finisher shirt.
And they finally came in and we literally...
I mean, Lucy is probably still packaging them up right now,
but we've sent out hundreds of...
We did the full triathlon.
We did the full with us
hundreds, hundreds of shirts.
We had four full boxes of shirts.
I mean, we ran out of bags
and I counted how many shirts we didn't have bags for
and it was 50.
Wow.
And that was after we ran out of shipping bags.
Yeah, yeah.
And so that many people
and most of them, it was their first, like they just...
And we had people that would show up and like,
okay, day 15, they're gonna do part of the bike ride
and see how the pacing goes
and then they showed up and did part of the run.
Or they would see who was finishing the full triathlon
and they were like, if that guy can do it, I can do it.
If that girl can...
I mean, Clint, a 15 year old kid came out and did,
had no like triathlon background at all.
He had no cleats on his bike shoes
Yeah, he bought a bike two weeks before or something
and he'd gotten out.
He was falling over
at intersection, he was so exhausted.
He guided it out.
It was so fun to see
these young kids
Then he rallied
and was bringing friends in.
And Hunter Sweating, he's just graduated
and he's Lucy's age, and he's had a really rough upbringing
and he lost 70 pounds, almost doing 75 par
and this was his last final project.
He did a full triathlon
and he finished it two o'clock in the morning,
well after the group had finished.
And what about the, I forget his name, the Hispanic guy?
Takashi?
Yeah, oh right, yeah.
I loved Takashi.
Yeah, he never swam, never biked, never ran,
got it out that full thing.
He just posted a picture, he's proudest can be
with his conquered shirt on.
He's the most delightful person on this planet.
And Seif?
How do you say his name?
Seif, yeah, Seif, oh, Seif.
Seif, Seif
Yeah Seif.
Yeah, from India.
India by way of Dallas, like a PhD student
who literally moved.
Like he just set up shop in Lindon
and was doing his classes remotely
and showed up for the marathon
day after day after day.
And when he finished,
his last day was several days before we finished,
but he was borderline hysterical at the finish line.
Like he just sat and hugged me
and cried and cried and cried.
His life was forever transformed.
He said this has changed my life forever, cute Seif.
And another really cool story
is an individual that followed us
before the 50 through the 50
was a massive supporter, Noah Josh Powell.
Oh, Josh Powell.
And Josh said,
my goal by the end of this campaign
is to be able to complete one marathon with you guys.
And he would start way before us
and he wouLd get dropped.
And still get dropped.
And couldn't finish.
And by the end of it,
he did the last, I think weeks
worth of marathons with us.
He did a full a marathon a day for seven days
of the last part and was with us.
And he just was so proud,
had the biggest smile on his face,
but he literally couldn't finish a 10k with us
when he started.
Yeah.
And he just showed up every single day,
he's got a special needs daughter
and he would set up aid stations for us
and she was out there cheering for us.
A single dad with special needs daughter
and he was just like, this is a goal of mine.
I'm gonna do this with you guys.
I'm gonna give you all the support you need.
It's stories like that and Seif, and Takashi-
When Alex, who follow us on the 50
and then came out and did his first full marathon,
I think he started four hours before you.
And his goal was to just finish the marathon.
And he finished 10 minutes after.
10 minutes after us and was just balling.
Just these stories.
Amazing.
And those are just the stories of the people
that we got to interact with on-site.
The hundreds of messages globally that came in and said,
hey, because of your journey,
it has given me hope on my journey
and this is what I'm struggling with.
And individuals, hey, I was about to take my own life
and your journey started and it's given me hope
and I'm fighting again.
I mean, you wonder why,
for me personally, I wonder why I do things like this
and I joke that my gift is the ability to suffer
and there's not a lot of benefit to having this gift.
And then we receive literally hundreds of messages
from around the world of these people
that say your suffering has given me hope
on the journey that I'm on,
and that is just like soul shaking
when we receive those.
Even though we remember them
we remember names, we remember experiences.
Yeah, it's really beautiful.
I mean, there was a sense of that with the 50,
every state that you were in,
it seemed like you would pick up a few more people
than the day prior and there was like a momentum thing
that was happening
that culminated with you doing the final one in Utah
and all the people that showed up for that.
I mean, that was like bananas.
So you had to have some sense
that you could replicate that on some level,
but I think just being in the same place every single day
created this like force field, like a tractor beam, right?
That was attracting all of these people
who knew they could just show up.
It's like, hey, people like,
I got on a plane this morning and can't...
It was wild.
It was wild, it was wild
and we didn't know what to expect
because travel restrictions and COVID and all that,
and just every single day.
What shocked me more was the cycling community
that came out.
And then like Sunny would do a live every single day
on the swim, and then she'd give me a rundown
of the different countries that were live that day.
And then we started shipping out shirts to like Lithuania,
Poland, Iceland, and we're just like-
I'm really good with geography
and there's some countries and like, I gotta look that up.
Like I've never had to look a country up.
The far corners of the planet.
And I think for me, and what people need to realize
is you never know who's watching
and you never know who you're going to,
or who you can impact,
and we had no idea that our small family and the journey
and the crazy adventures that we do
would end up being this global type of impact
and changing the way people think about the journey
that they're on, and that's so humbling
when you think of how big the world is
and the reach that social media has nowadays
and the power.
Yeah, it's really the best
what social media is able to do.
Yeah, who needs media coverage?
Not us, social media did a lot for us.
It's all just so powerful.
I mean, I would just every day,
like, okay, what's going on?
There was something about the consistency of it,
like this Metro norm, like, okay, here's when...
You climbing out of the pool every day
and putting the crocs on,
I was like, okay, I can start my day now.
He's out of the pool, he put the crocs on,
I can go out and do my thing.
I gotta see the crocs
before I can like legitimately go out into the world.
He told and he was like there's James.
There's a swim towel that I got him for Christmas
which have their names and people.
And we're like, "Wait, what happened?
You changed the James towel."
'Cause James says it's not absorbent enough,
I want a different towel and then everybody freaked out,
whoa, whoa, oh, back to the James towel.
So I hung a good towel in the bathroom
and still wrapped in that James towel.
Because as normal
and as routine things needed to be for us,
I think people started to expect
this certain routine.
Yeah, the crocs
and the James towel.
The crocs and the towel
and Lucy waiting for me to roll in off the bike,
and they just expect these moments every single day
to happen.
You gotta capture that.
As long as you get that one thing every day,
like that's an important piece in the story
that needs to be told every day.
Which is funny
because it was totally not the same for us every day,
but that created an illusion of normalcy.
Normalcy.
Normalcy, normalcy, exactly.
Adam Skolnick told me that,
when he was down, kind of like hanging out with you guys
and he did the swim on either the second to last day
or whatever it was,
that I mean, you did, I don't know, what did you...
You broke it up into a set of 100 every day, right?
So that the swim would be essentially exactly
the same amount of time every day.
But you would kind of come into the wall
and then everyone would wait for you to go,
there's a weird like cult thing to that.
Like, okay, James is pushing off, we can push off now.
It was amazing.
And I had to stand a certain way in the pool
or I would immediately cramp up.
And so I had to be very particular with where I stood,
how I stood, how I pushed off of each wall.
And it just so happened we were on the far south lane
and all the other lanes were to the north of us,
and it just so happened I had to stand facing south.
So I never saw any of this type of activity
because I always had to have my back to everybody else
that was there, so.
Well, he wasn't the first swimmer,
so the first swimmer is kind of on the right side.
'Cause I had two basics.
He's waiting here
to get his turn to go to the other lane to hit.
So he wasn't even in position to face everybody
to his left.
And then I saw
some of the coolest footage I'd ever seen.
It was a drone and it was on day 100
when all lanes were filled and we would...
I'd push off,
and all of a sudden all lanes would start to move
and it was this like giant snake.
And then when I'd stopped, everyone would come in and stop
and then we'd get going again, it was just this really cool.
And he says that, and I'm like, I saw that every day,
you didn't see that?
Yeah, and I never saw it until I...
Once you start to break something down and look back on it,
you start to see footage and stuff,
'cause you're in the middle of it.
Everyone's like, oh my gosh,
Sunny's closet talks, have seen these?
And I'm like, no, I haven't seen.
No, you were riding your bike.
I have no idea what you guys are talking about.
Like, oh, Sunny's closet talk was epic today
and I'm like, okay.
He's like, what is a closet talk?
What's a closet talk?
And they're like the wing men, blah, blah, blah
and I'm like what are you guys talking about?
And it was all these things
that became normal to everybody else
that I had no idea was happening.
Right.
'Cause the wingman breakdown happened
when I was getting therapy,
the closet talk happened when I was-
Wingman wrap up.
There it is, wingman wrap up.
So all these things would happen that I had no idea.
So when I saw that really cool footage
of that snake that you were talking about
when everybody would push off the same time as me,
I was like, that's really cool.
We'll be back in a sec,
but first, if you dig this podcast
and I hope you dig this podcast,
then I think you'll really enjoy my latest book,
Voicing Change.
Featuring excerpts from poignant essays by
and glorious photography of some 50 of my favorite guests
over the last eight plus years of doing this thing,
this podcast.
It's a gorgeous artful compendium of the show
and copious wisdom shared there in,
all wrapped in a hardcover coffee table form
that provides a great taste of what we do here at the RRP
and serves as a beautiful keepsake
or gift for the ardent fan.
The book is only and exclusively available on our website,
signed copies are available
and we are shipping globally direct to any coffee table
on planet earth.
So to learn more and snag your copy today,
visit richroll.com/vc.
That's rich roll.com/vc.
All right, let's get back into it.
What day was the bike wreck on?
59.
Yep.
That could have toppled the whole thing.
Well, here's a very interesting part about that wreck,
one, it was very violent,
it was the hardest I've ever crushed.
I believe I got knocked out.
I didn't realize it was that bad.
It was that bad.
And I think that's part of the...
I got a concussion on that day for sure.
And what was interesting was the decision I had to make
because I had reset my history.
We were at 59
and I had done everything that I'd set out to do.
And that was one of those things like your leg snapping
and a bike crash, something catastrophic
where the public goes, yeah that makes sense,
you couldn't continue, we get it.
And so that was one of those moments
where I like had to really gut check and be like, oh, okay,
you did enough that it's acceptable,
you've made it past those personal benchmarks
that you wanted, you've kind of reset history,
now you have a decision maker.
Now it's a matter of doing 100
because you said you were gonna do 100,
and keep going.
And I remember laying there on the ground
and I came back to really quick and they asked me that...
My eyes were still closed and I could hear them saying,
they were on the phone calling the ambulance and I was like,
oh crap, it's over, 'cause I couldn't...
When you crash, you've got so much adrenaline dump.
And I was like, okay, they're calling an ambulance,
maybe I can't see, maybe my leg sticking out sideways
or something,
then I realized it was for the other person in the crash,
and it was way worse.
So it was a woman ahead of you,
someone caught in her spoke or something.
Yeah, and it was like, she ran into a brick wall
and she went straight over her bars
and her face was the first thing to hit the ground.
Aaron says, I looked at the left
and all I see is a bike flying through the air
and it's like, oh my gosh, that bike's gonna land,
and it just hit.
And I was the person right behind her.
And so I hit her as she was in air
'cause it slowed her down and stopped her,
but her face was literally
the first thing that hit the ground.
She was definitely knocked out
and need an ambulance and medical attention.
And as they were saying, calling the medical,
I was like, ah, crap, this whole thing's over.
And I reached up and I felt my collar bones
and I'm like, oh, they're not broken.
Right, that's the first thing you check.
And then they asked me a couple of quick questions
and I answered them right away, and I'm like, I'm okay.
And then I was like, yes, I crashed, and I'm okay
and we're gonna be able to continue
'cause that just adds to the story, right?
And then we made sure that she was okay,
the ambulance was on our way
and most of the cyclist stayed with her.
I went and talked to her and she was like,
"Please don't wait for me, go, I'm safe, I'm okay."
And she was super kind.
And me and three other cyclists-
Imagine how bad she felt.
Yeah.
Me and three other cyclists finished that bike ride
and then continued on.
And it was one of those decisions
or moments in the entire journey
where it's like, okay, this is a pivotal decision,
and I'd be lying if I didn't say like,
okay, I need to weigh what public opinion is gonna be
on this decision 'cause during the 50,
we made a lot of decisions
and didn't care what public opinion was
'cause we were on our own journey,
we were figuring out, nobody had done this before,
but this one I did care
because I wanted to get through this with a clean slate
as far as public opinion is concerned.
And so kind of those big decisions I made, I was like, okay,
I'm conscious of what the public is gonna do with this,
and so I was like, no, we're gonna continue and I'm capable.
And that became part of my decision process every single day
was like, okay, am I capable of continuing
or is this a good enough excuse to quit?
Like I'd wake up in the morning,
and I was always amazed, I'm like, man, Hayden is a genius.
Like I put me together every single night.
I'd wake up and I'd be like, crap I can get in the water,
like I don't have a good enough of a reason
to not start today.
And then I'd start biking and I'm like,
no, I just don't have a good enough reason,
and then I'd get on the run and I'd be walking
and I'm like, well, my leg hasn't broken yet,
and this really sucks and I'm managing the pain,
but this isn't a good enough reason,
and that became my decision process every single day.
Is this a good enough of a reason to quit?
Will the public buy off on this?
No, okay, I've gotta keep going.
Yeah.
My story, that bike real quick
is that when he got up and rode off,
everybody's like, I guess he's good.
That happened a lot faster than he remembers,
that he crashed, he assessed, he checked on her
and he was gone,
and all the cyclists were like, whoa, whoa, whoa,
where's James?
He's off, he's gone.
So he made that decision that quickly.
What day was it when you made the little video
before you got in the pool and you were tearing up
and your like-
80.
I'm just gonna try today.
You look like you were...
I mean, I don't know if that was the nadir
of the whole thing,
but if there was a breaking moment, that looked like one.
It was, and it was so interesting
because I had never gone live before that moment,
I didn't go live after that.
Like, I mean, before the swim
and I just felt compelled to turn on my phone
as I'm walking from the car to the pool,
I mean, it's probably 200 meters to get to there.
And for some reason I turned on my phone
and I was just gonna give an update on how I was feeling,
and then I just got completely overwhelmed by emotion,
and it was this insanely impactful moment for the viewers.
And it just like really resonated with people
on the journeys that they were on.
They really got to see, okay, he is broken,
he is really struggling and he still has 20 more days
and he's not gonna quit.
That's almost three weeks.
I mean, 80 to 100 sounds close,
but that's almost three weeks.
That is a long time.
It's the craziest thing
with perspective
'cause you're like I'm gonna do 20 iron mans.
People would say, that's insane,
but you're like, well, you've done 80 you only have 20.
Yeah.
And that became
so frustrating for me
because it was like, oh, you're so close,
you're right there, right-
So he's thinking three weeks,
the public's thinking only 20 more, right?
Right, that's not how...
I mean, it's coming from a good place,
that's well intention,
but it's actually really not what you wanna hear.
It's not how we process.
And so that was really the peak
'cause I was going through all the pain.
I was processing everything.
I know what the family is going through at this point,
I know what Sunny's enduring,
I know we're struggling as a couple,
I know all these things are happening,
and I know the wingmen, they're falling apart.
Everybody's really struggling.
It just showcased how long of a journey this was
for that type of thing.
And again, I don't know why, but I turned on my phone,
I was just gonna share a few thoughts
and then I had that breakdown moment.
And after that moment,
that day's ride became very meaningful.
Every single support that we had,
that like the cyclists
that would come out once or twice a week,
I didn't know this, but they were all
on a big text read together.
I mean all the different cycling clubs unified.
That's so special, isn't it?
They unified during this time
and they were all on a text read
and a text read went out immediately.
Anybody see that moment,
anybody see that-
Collaborating,
make sure there's people there, so special.
Every single one of them figured out a way
to take work off that day,
all of them showed up on that one day.
And it was super interesting
because not a word was said on the bike ride.
Everybody just said,
it was kinda like just like a memorial type of a ride
where they're like, we are here,
we're gonna get you through today,
you don't need to say anything
and tomorrow we'll fight again.
And to me, I think that was a big turning point
in us getting to the finish.
'Cause for me, where I was sitting,
not from the outside looking in,
but from my journey where I was sitting in the last 15
were ultra flow state for me.
And I knew after that breakdown
and I knew after the community had come out
and when I had 15 to go, I was like, this is in the bag.
And I agreed that we're so close,
but that's when I became super flow state
and just like every moment of every day matters.
And you look at my time over the last 15 days
and it was a metronome type of state, yeah.
It was just execution at a high level.
So that was the inflection point?
I mean, what is the self-talk or the mantra
or the the kind of go to emotionally
that you rely upon in those moments
where on the flip.
On the day 80?
That day or any other day.
When you're up against it and you're backed into a corner
and everything inside of you wants to quit,
how do you crawl out of that headspace?
You shift your focus to the community
and it becomes, you're not showing up for me,
I'm showing up for the other people.
And by that point in the journey
we'd received so many messages
of, "Your journey has impacted me in this way."
And then you have the conversation with yourself
what I alluded to earlier, we never know who's watching,
you never know who you're impacting.
And so you immediately switch the conversation to,
if I don't show up today,
who am I missing an opportunity to impact?
And we'll never know, but who did we impact
that didn't see or know of our story
prior to day 80 tuned into it
and then we completely changed their paradigm
or the way that they look
or the way they experience what they're doing,
because we didn't stop or quit,
and so that becomes a conversation of the mantra.
It shifts from you or me
to who are we gonna miss an opportunity to impact
if we don't show up today.
And will you quit on day 80
and you don't get to have, in my opinion,
the most impactful day, which is 101.
That doesn't even exist, not even in the narrative,
you can't set that example, you can't lead from the front,
you can't bring everybody with you to that moment,
without that conversation and that mindset of like,
who am I missing the opportunity to help today?
I think something that gets missed in this story
is the fact that you're able to execute
on this goal by dent of the fact
that you have incrementally worked your way up
and accumulated knowledge and experience
over many years and many challenges.
And it's not a situation where
I think the instinct in people who hear this,
it's just it's so unrelatable,
they're like, well, he's a crazy, super human person
and I don't get that.
So yeah, maybe he can throw some platitudes my way,
but I can't even wrap my head around that
and the truth is very different.
It's not like you're this...
Your gift really is that you're able to suffer,
but you have figured out a way to express that
through these challenges
that get incrementally more and more difficult
over the years that allow you to kind of be in the place
that you're in now.
I didn't say that very articulately,
but you know what I'm saying?
Like this starts on a Ferris wheel for 10 days
and it's not like you're out winning triathlons right away
or anything like that,
you have a very different path into this kind of thing.
I think that is the most beautiful or profound lesson
that needs to be heard today is-
It is looked over.
That is looked over
that nobody's the expert
at the beginning of their journey, nobody is.
And you have to meet yourself where you're at today
and that'd be the expectation.
The hardest thing to do is to start on any journey
because that's where the highest amount of struggle is,
that's where our experience and our momentum
and our success is at its lowest.
And a lot of people see the headline, the 100 and think,
oh, he's just born to do this kind of thing.
And I love saying it now
that you can't go from zero to 100
and miss all of the moments in between.
I mean, our journey started with a four-mile fun run
that I struggled through,
and Sunny and I got into sprint triathlons together
and did that for four years before even taking on
the scariest thing to us at the time,
which was a half Ironman.
I mean it was 2004, November of 2004 was that fun run,
that was a long time ago.
Yes and no, like given what you've done,
it's actually not that long ago.
What we've accomplished in that time.
It feels like a lifetime ago.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Yeah, it is.
But the important message is
is that nobody would have said
that that individual would have gone on
to set sports endurance history,
and everybody has a beginning, middle,
and end to their journey
and we're not even close to our end
as far as like what we wanna do.
Oh and you don't always get to know what the journey is.
So like, even for us, we're like,
oh, we don't even know how this actually ends
'cause we're still young.
But it's the audacity
to start and the courage to put one foot
in front of the other,
and I think a lot of people just get caught up
in needing to understand how it's gonna unfold
and they get paralyzed and never actually move forward.
That was beautifully said,
but two, they're two...
And social media, this is the bad part about social media
is they're comparing themselves
against what other people are doing
or showing that they're doing.
And they say, I can't do that and I'm not good enough
and that's what stops them from starting.
And that's tragic to me
because thankfully, social media wasn't big
when we started and I didn't have basis of comparison
to people like, oh, who are your mantra?
I mean, who are your mentors?
And who's this and that and who do you look on to?
And I was like-
I don't know.
Yeah.
You used to say your grandma,
you used to always say your grandma.
Yeah, my grandmother.
An immigrant that started a business
and made a life for herself.
Yeah, she's the ultimate
American dream that happened in Canada.
But I would not compare myself
to what the current standard of excellence was,
and I would go out
and try to do what I believe was possible.
And here's the perfect example,
at the time when I said I was gonna do the 50,
the baseline was kind of like the epic five, right?
And had I looked at that and said, oh, the epic five
is the standard of excellence at the time, which it was,
I would have said, okay, I'm gonna double that standard
to do 10, so why did I go all the way to 50?
Because for me personally, I wasn't comparing myself
about what others were doing or accomplishing,
I went out and I set the standard of the bar
to what I thought I could do.
And that's where people get into problems and struggles
is they are now comparing themselves
to what they see the top, top guy is doing
and they just get overwhelmed and they don't start.
And so there's two sides of that coin, right?
Don't get sidelined by what you see people are doing
and then don't look what other people are doing
and do what you believe is possible within yourself.
So there's two kind of different looks at that.
But also you can be inspired
by what other people are doing.
Take it as inspiration, yes.
Well, don't copycat it,
our society loves to copy cat.
Or James love triathlon and loves sports
and that all the stuff,
he didn't copy anything that anybody else did,
he found his own level excellence,
his own creative idea on how to be successful
in the industry.
It's fake, it's made up, he made this thing up.
What do you mean you're gonna do a full distance triathlon
in every state?
What about Hawaii and Alaska?
It's this made up thing.
So people should feel empowered to create their own dreams
and their own aspirations based on what they see,
but not copycat them, get creative, do something different.
I remember, do you remember, I saw you guys at the airport
when you were heading to Hawaii?
Sure do, met wife.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
There they go, man.
Listen to me, your wife was so nice
and I could tell she almost pitied me.
Like these people think-
Have no idea.
I don't think so.
No, this is what I felt like,
like these guys are so nice and I feel so bad,
they think they can do a 50 full distance tract.
It was this energy of they're cute, it's naive.
They're so cute and they're naive.
Because she was coming from-
You make it sound condescending though.
No, no, not at all.
It wasn't, it wasn't.
Because she was coming from the perspective of experience
having with your your journey and whatnot.
And she was like, okay.
I mean, even-
She was so nice.
She was taking her lead for me though
'cause I was like,
this guy he's gonna do something great,
like I just don't...
And I've said this to you,
I think he's physically capable of doing this,
but the logistics, like if one thing goes wrong,
like the whole thing craters,
and you think you're gonna go across 50 states
and something's not gonna like-
It was so kind, it was so supportive
and it was almost like this, oh, you guys bless your hearts
if you're gonna do this thing.
It's amazing
how much our journeys have kind of intertwined
over the past decade.
Was that so weird to see each other at the airport though?
That was the weirdest thing.
I know, it's was crazy.
On our way to Hawaii in boat,
like on our way out the door.
I know, wild.
I know the exact picture, I'm holding Quinn,
he's wearing that green hat on.
He that the sunglasses on there like crooked.
I know and then you fricking went out and did it
and I remember coming out like it was emotional for me.
I don't know if you remember when we did that podcast
after you finished, I got like choked up
'cause I was so touched by what you guys had done
and the manner in which you carried yourself
and the way that you chose to express this incredible thing
and the community that you had built.
And that was my first experience
getting to meet Casey and Erin,
and those guys are just...
I mean, they're unbelievable those guys,
the positivity and the loyalty
and just the extent to which those guys show up for you
is a testament to you guys as leaders
because you don't get people like that
unless you engender that level of kind of like trust
and love and respect.
Yeah, they are huge, huge parts of our journey.
And what's interesting is I have a different relationship
with those two guys and Sunny has a different relationship
with those two guys
and their relationships with each other is different.
It's just a very...
And the way we got to meet those guys was so random
and it was just happen chance
that they were the only two guys available
that would agree to doing the 50.
We didn't even know them.
But that's the way it works.
It is the way it works
and they have just totally become family and-
Well Aaron did every one of those bike rides,
every single bike ride,
Aaron was out there doing every mile.
He's about to go crush-
And I gotta tell-
He's hopefully
'cause it was James, it was amazing.
When I came out on day 91,
I mean, it was great and all of that,
but the highlight of the day
was doing the wingman wrap-up in the field.
I was like, now I'm in it,
now I get to be on the wingman wrap up,
like, this is why I came.
You were the guest to them
not them the guest to you
They're special boys.
Unbelievable, I remember
on the day 100, when I came out,
you were so in the zone
and it was clear you were trying
to really minimize your interactions
with other people and just focus
on what you were trying to accomplish.
But you did say, I was like, 'cause you were walking
and I was like, are you gonna break out the run?
And you're like, yeah,
I think you said at mile 20,
you were gonna let it loose and throw it down
and things didn't actually go to plan.
Yes, so we had that conversation on 91.
Yeah, yeah, yeah,
and then on day 100, I was like, okay, you're gonna,
yeah, he's like, I'm gonna drop.
You said I'm gonna drop the hammer.
Yes, as we were running.
'Cause on day 100,
oh man, I was being so patient
and allowing my body to recover.
Wait, pause and we knew there was a 101,
but nobody else did.
So then he's like...
Well, because
and I'm sure we'll get to 101 pretty quick here,
but we didn't make the decision to do 101
until that Sunday, the final decision, so three days before.
And when I had talked to you on that-
You had the shirts made up and everything.
In 48 hours.
Oh, you did, wow.
And they were hand delivered.
Yeah, it's crazy.
And people think it was planned because we had the jersey,
but that was a-
It was like how'd did you get that jersey?
We're like, we don't know.
We don't know.
It literally hand delivered in two days.
Well, when we had that conversation on day 21,
I mean on day 91, I was being super patient,
my shin was healing, I didn't have any pain,
I was on the other side of the hip,
I was just like, I am going to run that last day.
And right from the go, I started to run
and I got to, I was so excited,
but I knew things started to go south
because I had already I mean, obviously asked
so much from my body and my mind.
I mean, we're at the very tail end of a quarter of a year,
had done something nobody thought was physically possible.
And I had just really nursed my body back to health
in the midst of so much trauma and so much stress
and I made it all the way to 19, Rich.
I made it to mile 19 running.
And then, like you said,
if things went sideways in the beginning of the campaign,
they went sideways on day 100 and day 19.
And I don't remember a lot of it
because I had to check out
and I just remember the wing men were there
and Felicia was there.
Our 110 pound friend who'd be the one to catch him.
And I just remember, I'd manage it, manage it
and then my legs just...
I had asked everything out of them
and they would give out on me
and the collapsed moments,
but I had gave me the 30 seconds to recoup
and mentally we had a mantra and it was here we go
and when you said, here we go, we start moving again.
And I remember we were on the last Out N Back
headed up to 8th North
and we probably had three miles to go,
it was after 19, I'd fallen apart.
I had lost my goal to run the whole thing
'cause my legs kept giving out on me
and we were probably mile 22 or 23 and I lost it again
and Felicia caught me.
And right before I went down,
I was looking at my watch and I said,
how fast are we running?
And she's like, we're running at 9:30.
And then my legs gave out and I collapsed again
and then I got back up and I said,
I can do better than this.
And her jaw dropped
because she's like, you're on day 100
of 100 consecutive Ironmans.
You have given everything you got,
you've given everything you've had or had
and your mindset right now is I can do better than this.
And that's truly where my mind was
because you wanna go out
kind of with a bang, like we did on the 50.
And I had been dreaming of it for a long time on that run
and being so patient, allowing my body,
and I've obviously asked a lot for my body,
but it was kind of that moment where
like it was a proud moment for me because I was at the end,
but my mind was still there from my perspective,
and even in that moment, I knew I could do or be more.
For people that don't know, I mean, in the final miles,
you were literally collapsing,
you were passing out and people had to catch you.
Did you ever fall all the way down to the pavement?
I didn't,
and it's crazy 'cause I've seen pictures now
where it was bad.
It was bad.
And I've seen pictures now where like Casey and Aaron
are like right there.
Any stumble or anything that I do,
they are right there anticipating it.
And I wouldn't have made it the last day without them
just because of the pace that we're pushing,
we'd done five hours on the bike course, which is moving.
And so I'd asked a lot from my body just on that bike ride,
knowing it was the last day, but also knowing...
We didn't wanna let on that we were gonna do 101,
and I had been telling people
on social media the whole time,
I'm gonna run 100, brace yourself.
If you plan to join me that day, we're moving,
we're gonna go sub 12, 11,
and then things fell apart.
But at the back of my mind, I said,
okay, I can't allude
to the fact that I got to get up and do this again tomorrow.
So even after I broke myself
and drove myself into the ground,
I had to figure out a way to do it one more time.
We had to fake celebrate.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Fake celebrate
the whole night.
I knew about it,
you told me about it, Adam knew about it.
I mean, I remember-
There was like six people
that knew about it.
Oh, yeah, Adam,
'cause Adam would have known.
Adam and I went down to the finish line
and we were kind of helping set up and all of that,
and then Adam got word from Lucy, I think
like, oh, James is really struggling,
he's a couple miles out
and then we jogged up to join the group.
So I was there, I saw like maybe the last mile
and a half of that,
and I was like, oh my God, I don't think he's...
Like he's so close and it just might not happen.
And you're like, he's got to do 101 tomorrow.
I'm like, forget about that,
let's just get him into the track of the high school.
And then running around the track,
like you came back to life
and you started actually running pretty fast there
at the end.
I just couldn't believe like you were literally falling down
and you couldn't figure out
how to put your foot on the ground without tripping.
It's just so crazy the power of the mind
and when you're so close to something
and the ability to turn it off.
Like Casey and Aaron are having a hard time keeping up
on that last lap 'cause they had done the full thing.
It was also really hot.
It was hot.
And neither of them were trained
for a full distance triathlon
and Aaron had biked all of those days.
So Aaron's like I almost couldn't keep up.
Aaron said, one more half lap
and I would've fallen over.
And I just kept praying the entire time,
I was picking up that pace over the last two laps,
I was just like, don't fall on your face
in front of everybody.
Even though I've been doing it for six miles prior to this,
but I'm like, you're in the grand stand now
and every step I took,
I couldn't believe it,
I didn't fall over, I didn't fall over, I didn't pull over.
And I just like kept just saying, stay in your feet,
stay in your feet,
stay in your feet.
How cool was that flag
that you ran under?
It was really cool.
It was very cool.
It was a cool moment.
And then 20 minutes later,
you're up giving a speech, looking fresh as a daisy,
it's like crazy.
Standing for like 45 minutes
and I'm like, get the man a chair.
Well, man, I did pictures for two or three hours.
You guys were there for a long time.
Pretending that there was no-
Two or three hours knowing I'm like,
okay, I got to get home, I got to get on the therapy table,
I've got one more day.
So I left at 8:30
and you had left about 15 or 20 minutes before that,
so you were out of there by 8:10.
The 101 just being like the core group,
like just close friends.
And that was even special too
'cause I was planning on just me, Aaron
and Casey kind of doing it.
We had celebrated, we had celebrated
and people probably wanted their rests too
from the whole thing,
and Lucy went live every single day on the swim.
Sunny did.
Oh yeah, oh yeah, sorry, Sunny did.
Lucy would push the button.
He lose your partners.
Yes,
and we wanted that moment
to where it was just me in the pool
and that's why we didn't tell anybody.
And I started that swim by myself
and the chat boards
and text threads kinda lit up immediately.
Which we exactly wanted, the element of surprise.
We wanted that conversation.
With just an instance
of like, wait a second, he's swimming.
Is this recovery swim, what's happening?
And I imagine people thought, oh, he can't sleep
and he's gonna kind of give a breakdown
of what happened.
Right,
this poor guy doesn't know what to do with himself
so he gotta do it again.
And then by the time I finished the swim
and got out of the water,
the cyclists had got together
and then started meeting us on the road.
And then we did an undisclosed run location
'cause we wanted it to be kind of friends
and family in core.
Day 100 was so chaotic,
it's the opposite of my personality.
It was so stressful, we had hundreds of riders out there
and last thing you want to do is crash at high speeds
on the last day when you're that close,
and so it was a super stressful bike ride for me,
and then obviously the excitement and the emotion
and the stress from that run.
And so I wanted to kind of go out on my terms
and the feeling on that day was so different
'cause we'd accomplished the goal, we did it.
Yeah,
We did it
and so that's like the biggest of exhales happened.
And then it was just this fun,
chatty core group of cyclists and runners
that we got to experience and kind of go out on our terms
and it was a magical day.
Because you knew you'd finished,
there's no timeline, there's no expectations,
it's the ultimate victory lap with your closest team
and supporters from the past however long.
But it also sends a very loud and clear message
that when you've accomplished your goal
and done the thing you didn't think that you could do,
you can actually do more.
Yeah.
And it just was made undeniable.
Well I would always get so frustrated speaking
and someone would always ask after the 50,
could you have done one more?
And I was like, they are not gonna ask me
if I can do one more after this 100.
And then like we mentioned earlier,
it was not part of the game plan.
The week before we started to put it into play
and Zoka Cycle and Clothing,
we called her up and we said, hey, we have this idea,
we know it's in three days, any chance?
And she's like, send me the logo.
And her team was planning to drive
and be at the finish line,
and they handed that 101 jersey to Lucy
at the finish line after,
and I put it on the first time that following morning
and came out in that 101 jersey.
And so that was one of those little things
that looked like we had a plan,
but it came together so fast
and everyone was willing to do their part
to make that day happen.
So you've had some time now to reflect on all of this,
perhaps get a little bit of an objective, perspective
on what it was all about.
So what does it mean to you?
Like what is this all about
and has that kind of changed or evolved?
I don't think we know.
So James thought, I need to take some time off afterwards,
which just led him into depression
and no misdirection in his life
and he's just barely now picking back up.
He said in the middle of August, end of August
is when I kind of picked back up.
But I don't think we really know.
I mean, my recovery didn't start till two weeks ago
'cause I had to care for James post
and then we have summer and all the things we have going on,
and so it wasn't until the kids went back to school
that I finally like exhaled.
So I don't even think we've actually had the time
to reflect yet
because the summer, even though it was supposed...
I mean, it was very relaxing for James,
but not for, me and Lucy for instance, or the other kids.
This is your time,
you get to do what you wanna do now, I think.
Yeah, yeah, I mean, it's literally catching my breath.
Nothing has been routine since December for me
until just barely two weeks ago.
And here's the way any project happens
is there's a preparation, there's an execution
and then there's a post,
which is in our case, it's recovery.
And that recovery still was intense for Sunny
and caring for me and me going through those struggles
and going out of it.
And so this kind of been like this trip kind of like,
okay, kids are back to school, full time,
kids are in their routine
and this trip has kind of been like,
oh, this is kind of the first time
where both of us have been almost stress free
and relaxed and to where we're starting to reflect.
And so this actual talk has been kind of the start
of what that, on the other side
of that person.
I think it's the first time
that I really actually thought about it, to be honest,
'cause even the last two weeks I've been doing all the tasks
that I've been putting off since last December,
like organizing the pantry
and getting shelves hung on the garage.
So I mean, I think this is the first time
that I've really actually reflected on it.
Other than reflecting every day, I kept a journal every day
and then did my closet talk every day.
So every day I was writing things down,
but I mean, like there's some PTSD
that still has to be worked through
that I don't think either of us has really processed it yet,
and we don't really know what's gonna happen
because we still don't know nothing.
We made everything wait until August to happen
and now it's just really August,
so it's like, I don't think we really know.
I mean, I can't speak for James, but for me.
Well, for me,
Sunny and I have always been on the same path
but different perspectives and different journey
because our roles are very different.
And my role now quickly goes back into provider
and to where I'm speaking full-time again.
And we're planning on writing the second book
and I'm working with the film documentary crew
to produce the second documentary
and different opportunities
just show up in my email every day.
And so I'm back into that world of business
and trying to monetize what we did
and trying to help as many people as we can
and relaunch our coaching platform.
I mean rewriting your presentation.
Yeah, rewriting that whole thing-
Yeah, rewrite that keynote.
Yeah, getting the messaging back
in it that we want.
And we learn lessons and we evolve too on these journeys
and we wanna share those and teach those lessons too.
I mean, I think if someone gives the same keynote
for 20 years, they're not evolving as a person either.
And if you listen to my keynote
over the past five or six years, it's the same story,
but the lessons change
and where I put emphasis changes on them
because I'm evolving as a person.
And so what's next for me is very different
than kind of what's next for Sunny,
outside of like our family goals and raising our kids.
But Sunny is loving doing podcasts
and getting into speaking,
it's actually what she wants to do
and empowering people.
I get contacted all the time.
And you and I had conversations recently, Rich,
we're like Sunny is the unsung hero of this journey.
And every time I speak people are like
who's your wife and can we meet her?
And she's an absolute-
You have to wake up and just do one thing every day.
Exactly.
She's gotta do
a thousand things
and keep her eye on so many moving pieces.
I know Sunny more than most,
and she's expressed many times how now is not the time,
but now is the time to prepare
for when she gets to tell her story
and be on stage and do that.
And so she's got some exciting opportunities coming up
and she's doing some speaking and prep work
and her entire focus forever has been
and still is the kids
and what an unbelievable responsibility that is
and the amount of work and the attention to detail
and time that she puts into each one of our kids
is remarkable.
Well your kids are great.
Like I love your kids.
They're so awesome.
They were born that way, I'm telling you.
I don't know about that.
Yeah, me neither.
It's a true testament to how much time and care
and love and thought that Sunny puts into it,
but her time is coming.
And from my perspective, that's what's coming for her,
she's just preparing, doing little things now
that'll prepare her for her true passion.
Her true passion is teaching people
and speaking and talking,
and mine is like disappearing into the mountains on my bike.
And so I'm waiting for that day
that we transition out of that.
If you have a chance to see James do his talk,
like what was that like three years ago,
when you were out here and you did it?
It's very good, you're very good at that.
Oh, thank you.
And I can't imagine how much it's evolved since I saw it.
So if you have an opportunity to attend an event
and to hear James share his story,
it's something you should definitely check out.
Oh, thank you.
And I look forward to Sunny's version, right?
It's so exciting, maybe a little more girly, I don't know.
But part of that talk and what you're all about
is this subject of mental toughness
and I'm sure people say to you all the time,
how do you develop mental toughness?
Where does your mental toughness come from?
Like what is that about?
How can I be more mentally tough in my own life?
The number one question.
Verbatim.
Yeah, and I had to think about it a lot,
because I didn't know how to answer it,
because I mean, if I could write out
that formula for someone,
my financial situation's completely different,
but the reality is is just through discussion
and presenting and really having the opportunity to be
and speaking in 48 different countries
and just all the different walks of life
in different cultures,
the number one thing is mental toughness
and I've just realized it's only through taking action.
It's only through getting backed into that corner
and then having the courage to take that next step saying,
my leg might snap, but I am willing to that next step.
And you cannot learn it by reading it,
you cannot learn it by hearing somebody,
those are all great sparks or motivation pieces
to get you going on your journey,
but ultimately at the end of the day,
you've got to show up, you've got to participate,
you have to learn.
And you can't go from zero to 100
and I couldn't have done what I did mentally
without learning and struggling
and developing and sharpening that thing.
The big question topic, are you born with it
or can you develop it?
Nature versus nurture.
The internal debate, right?
And my answer just based on my personal experiences,
it's nurture.
You have to develop it, you have to work on it.
Now we're all born with a different baseline.
Jace would be a great example.
He obviously has a different starting baseline
for mental toughness than some other people do.
Now, if he took-
And you're the kid
who was on the Ferris wheel
for 10 days to win a prize.
Exactly.
Right, exactly.
So your baseline
is probably a little bit different.
Like how old are you for that?
22?
21, 22.
Yeah.
But I took that knowledge
from that experience
and then I've really showed up in my life and sharpened it.
Jace has an incredible opportunity
to be something very special in that mindset space.
And I come across,
you can pick out, okay baselines
higher baselines, higher baselines, higher,
develop that talent, but everybody can develop it.
'Cause I'm a great example of this is a mental journey,
I'm not the most physically gifted, now you have to...
The other big question is, how much is physical
and how much is mental for what we do
or the journey that we're on?
And my answer has changed over the years,
and you hear a lot of people have different opinions.
It's like 70% mental and it's 100% physical
and it's 100% mental.
You cannot do what I did if I'm very strong mentally,
and I'm a 300 pound man.
Mentally, you cannot drag your body through that experience.
And if you're extremely physical,
but have a weak mind,
I've seen so many athletes
that are way more talented than I am fail
because they don't have the mental component of it.
And so you straight up have to be 100% on both of them
in order to accomplish something like that
or the journey or push your boundaries
or your limits, right?
It's a combination, you cannot rely solely
on one of the other
and allow that to be, to get you through,
you have to be so strong at both of them
or just doesn't work.
Yeah, it's really a habit or a muscle this idea
of reflexively putting yourself into positions
where you're going to be tested mentally,
emotionally, physically in all of these ways.
And we're in a culture right now
where it's kind of easy to opt out
of that type of situation.
So you have to almost have a little bit of extra gumption
to seek it out and put yourself in that situation.
Sunny always says, and she is not lying when she says it.
She says, if I have two paths in front of me,
I'm going to intentionally pick the harder one
because I wanna struggle, I wanna learn, I wanna grow,
and that's exact opposite
of what most people are doing today.
They see two things and go, that's easy route,
I'm gonna take that way.
And that individual, sadly-
It's very unfulfilling.
It's unfulfilling, they're not gonna grow.
Like you're diluted into thinking that
the happy life is the easy life,
but the happy life, the fulfilled life,
the purpose driven life
is the life that invites those sort of difficult situations
into your experience.
When they're depressed
and the anxiety and it seems...
I'm like, I'm sure you do,
because you're just taking that easy mountain bike path,
that it's just softer and all you do is...
There's no challenge,
there's no reason to develop any character,
but they're choosing them, right?
So it's like, well, I'm sure you feel depressed,
like you're accomplishing nothing hard.
So that's definitely what our culture
and our society encourages.
Yeah.
It's the easy part.
One of the biggest things you learned
by taking the harder path is problem solving,
and that's what our team
and Sunny has become experts at is problem solving,
that's all we do.
We've become master problem solvers
and we've learned how to problem solve
in the face of adversity.
And when you take that path of least resistance,
there's very limited opportunities
or necessity to problem solve,
and so you don't learn that skill set,
and life is about managing adversity
and learning how to problem solve at a high level.
Under stressful circumstances.
You're not problem solving.
So the problem
for you being overwhelmed
is probably really high.
Oh, yeah.
Like nothing's a big deal.
No, no, I'll just, I'll figure it out.
And I mean, that was the whole journey
of the 100 was adaptation, nothing was ever the same.
Every day, the mood, the injury,
the fatigue of the crew or James, the food he wanted,
the people that were showing up, the weather.
I mean every day was adaptation.
And I remember being late in the journey going,
man, we're in 90 days in, and nothing's ever the same.
You grocery shop for the week
and James doesn't want anything you buy,
and it's literally minute to minute to minute.
So I don't have a lot of tolerance for people who say,
it's just hard, I don't have the resources,
I can't figure it out.
And I'm like, dude, you just figure it out,
that's life, you just figure out,
nobody has the instruction manual,
nobody knows what they're doing, you just figure it out,
and a lot of times you don't have the time to figure it out.
You have like 10 seconds
to figure out a solution right here right now, I mean.
And that was the premise of the 100
was remove the chaos, put in normality,
put in consistency.
Create illusion.
Remove the chaos.
Good luck with that.
One of those things
that we thought we were gonna able to control
and ultimately it became-
It was exactly the same.
It became chaotic as the 50, but for twice as long.
Exactly the same, but different.
I mean, it was just as chaotic,
just as necessary to solve problems,
just as dramatic, just different.
It was unbelievably exactly the same
as far as emotions and stress.
What's a story that hasn't been told
like a behind the scenes, what do people not get
or not understand about how this whole thing unfolded?
From both perspectives, James what's yours?
I think, man, that's a great question,
I've never been asked that before.
You're a winner
'cause he gets asked a lot of the same questions.
I do this for a living.
That's pretty good.
This is my job.
Most people ask the same questions, you got him.
Gosh.
I will say this, few people will ever understand
what it takes and what the four of us went through,
even if you've read every book, seen every interview.
I mean it had to put a strain on your marriage?
No.
No?
Well...
Maybe his but not mine.
He's like, well I don't know,
actually was out there riding my bike.
No.
Even I didn't know.
I think Sunny is actually super mature
and one of the biggest size of relief for me when she says,
I just gave you 100 day pass on anything you said
and anything you did,
and I'm like, no other woman on the planet does that.
But just her level of understanding of,
okay, look, this isn't my husband
and there's an imbalance,
there's a hormonal thing going on,
there's a stress thing going on,
this is totally situational,
and thankfully I did get a 100 day pass.
I don't think people realize
that it was literally second to second.
I mean, and I don't know if that was everybody's experience,
but that was certainly mine.
I mean, from the second I got up
until I was climbing into bed,
knowing I was only getting two hours of sleep,
every second was high intensity and demanding.
I mean, there was no refuge.
So that I think about people in their own struggles
and there's a lot of times you're like,
okay, I'm gonna go in my closet and take five breaths.
Like that didn't exist for me because I had my family,
I had the crew, I had James,
I mean the film crew, James, I had our working crew,
I had the volunteer church stuff
I was doing in the community,
my parents live in my basement, we have two dogs.
I mean, there was literally...
A lot of people whose needs need to be met,
who are looking to you to meet those needs,
and not a lot of time for Sunny to meet Sunny's needs.
Which I knew was only temporary, so it was okay.
But 100 days is long, temporary phase.
Yeah, and it took me about two years
to recover from the 50, and so I promised myself this time,
along the way, I would do things
to prevent needing that much time to recover.
And so that's why now I'm like,
there's definitely still some PTSD that I have to process
that I just haven't had the chance to yet
and I've just started that.
So I definitely feel better than coming off the 50,
but it was intense every second.
Yeah, it's kind of like an extrapolated version of
when somebody goes into crew, like an ultra race
and they've never crewed before
and they think they're just gonna be in a van,
listening to music and it's gonna be super cool and chill.
And they're like, wait,
they're doing stuff all the like...
But that's times 1000 for 100 days straight.
Yeah.
I think the stories that haven't been told yet,
or the stories that we don't know yet
of the people we've impacted,
I think that's the biggest thing.
They are yet to come.
That are yet to come.
And those are obviously the most meaningful stories
and a lot of them we won't ever get to hear.
Back on the mental toughness piece,
you had mentioned something
that's a little bit tangential to it,
which is this idea of showing up, right?
The idea of being consistent
and how that plays into long-term success
and the truth being that it's not sexy
and it's not something
that trends in social media,
it's like that stuff
that you do every single day, no matter what
that moves the needle forward, ever so slightly,
that puts you in the position to be able to do great things
and achieve your dreams.
I got to have a really cool experience.
I've had the opportunity to speak to some NFL teams
and I was on the field for a warmup for one of the games
and one of the coach was there talking to me
and the quarterback was throwing the ball
to a couple of different receivers
and he said, watch this.
And he threw the ball and the receiver caught it
and immediately tucked it and then drop the ball,
caught the next one and immediately tucked it.
And then he started throwing the ball to a newer member
of the team where were rookie
and he would catch it and drop it, catch it and drop it
and he said, he's not gonna make it in this league.
And the reason he's a successful veteran
is because he's still doing the small things
and working on the fundamentals
that you would think they would take for granted
over not put much attention to it,
but the fact that it would catch it and still tuck it,
like it was in a game situation where he was protecting it,
even in just tossing a ball to you, right?
That type of thing.
The coaches watch that kind of stuff
and it's that level of consistency,
it's that level of showing up,
it's that level of doing the small things
over a long period of time that people aren't willing to do
that separates that guy who makes it
and that guy who ultimately will get cut.
Yeah, so true.
How does it work with balance?
I'm sure you get that question a lot too.
He does get that one a lot.
Yeah.
Your life's totally out of balance, dude.
No, it's not.
Well, you're guy with...
You have four kids, right?
Yeah.
So I'm sure you get that question a lot too, right?
I do.
My answer evolves, but I have kind of a response to that,
but I'm interested in how you guys think about that.
My answers have evolved too
and now that I have four teenage girls.
So fun.
It is fun,
but this is the example that I use.
My 13 year old daughter doesn't want like 25% of my time.
'Cause people like assume,
oh, family life balance.
You're lucky
if you get 5 minutes.
Well, yeah and people assume,
okay, let's say, let's break life into work, play, family.
And if balance equals 33, 33, 33,
then you've got to give that amount of time
to each one of those.
And that's the best example
is my daughter doesn't want 33% of my time,
that's absurd.
What she does want is when I am getting over my time,
she wants all of my time,
and she wants me to be right there, attentive,
listening to the story
that I don't necessarily all the details care about.
But I mean, we've got one daughter who Sunny will say,
how was your day?
And literally from when she woke up to when-
I woke up and I did this and then this
and its like...
Oh, the whole time?
I see, I would kill for that,
I get a lot of like fine
and that's all I get.
Yeah, we have one
of those too, how was your day?
"Fine," anything happened?
"No."
Yeah, but family life
and work balance doesn't mean an equal percentage,
it means whatever you're doing, give that balance to it.
And the 100 is a perfect example, totally out of balance,
but that imbalance is temporary
and the sacrifices were discussed with the families.
Everybody was committed to the imbalance
including the kids.
Okay, okay,
life's gonna be completely out of bounds
for a while, and it will shift back to imbalance.
And to break through barriers
and to reach certain levels and whatnot,
there has to be some...
Nobody that navigates this life successfully
has a perfect balance at all times.
Now what you have to be careful of
is going completely out of balance
for a really long period of time.
Now you're jeopardizing and creating problems.
What's your thoughts on balance?
I think that balance is ebb and flow,
it's like a marriage is never 50, 50,
sometimes it's 60, 40, sometimes it's 70, 30,
depending on which partner needs more attention at the time.
I think life is like that,
sometimes you don't need downtime, you need uptime.
You don't need to rest, you need to be more exhilarated
to have more passion.
So I think the appropriate thing with balance is gauging
where you're at personally, where your family's at,
what your goals are, what the demands are
and doing so accordingly,
because like you said, it evolves, right?
It changes over time.
Look, if you're writing a book,
your time balance is gonna be different
than when the book's complete
and your marketing the book.
Right.
Now your time and attention
is gonna go somewhere else
but it's the same project,
you're trying to accomplish the same goal,
but it has to sacrifice differently
to get to the end of that project.
Reviewing your activity level,
you're like I'm going to be sitting a lot more in the day
than if I'm working on my garden.
Yeah, I mean, it's a tricky thing.
I mean,
I think culture dictates this idea
that we should be aspiring to live our life
in this super balanced way every single day
and that our time and attention is equally apportioned
throughout the hours of the day
so that everybody's taken care of
and you're taking care of yourself
and it sets people up for failure and for guilt,
like we beat ourselves up
because we're not adhering to that kind of norm
and that norm is an illusion.
I don't think anybody adheres
to that norm successfully.
And on top of that, if you wanna do something amazing,
your life is gonna have to look unlike other people's lives.
I mean, that's just the truth,
nobody achieves something great
with some perfectly balanced life,
you have to be temporarily out of balance
so that something gets an extraordinary amount of time,
attention and focus.
It's your peaking period,
your peaking.
I think of it as a pendulum
and that pendulum has to swing back.
Like you have to make sure
that the important buckets in your life
are being attended to,
so that you don't capsize completely,
but you have to be in a situation
where you can kind of vacillate in and out of these things.
And that's okay,
as long as it always kind of like tips back
in the right direction.
Yeah, beautiful said.
And don't you think that people know
when their life is out of balance?
Sure.
'Cause either you're sad
or you're too tired or you're this or that
and then you assess, right?
Well our bodies are amazing too, they give us signals.
Yeah and I think,
I like to think of it more in terms of attention,
like where are you placing your attention
and is that the right place to be placing your attention?
And when you're placing your attention on that thing,
are you giving it all that you have
and you can pull out of it and then rejigger
and focus it somewhere else,
but being present for what you're doing.
And I think, a big piece of like the lesson that I extract,
one of the lessons I extract from the 100
is this mindfulness piece.
Like this idea of being totally present
with what you're doing, it's too overwhelming, right?
The only way that you got through it
is by being exactly where your feet were,
every second of every mile of every day.
Yeah, as soon as I looked too far ahead,
it was catastrophic.
Well, and you couldn't have balance.
He had one job.
Yeah.
Swim, bike, and run.
That was it.
If he tried to implement anything else, like you said,
he couldn't have accomplished it,
it couldn't have happened, right?
So, yeah, that was out of balance
but the appropriate thing to do
is to immediately balance out your time,
efforts and energies, as soon as that project is done,
and I think that's where people struggle.
I think they try to continue what they're doing,
they don't recover after a race,
they just continue their training,
but I think you articulated that beautifully.
Yeah.
And here, sorry,
here's a great example of, I sacrificed a lot of family time
during those 100 years-
100 years, that is what it felt like.
Get the MRI on that guy.
Immediately, 100 days, but what did that sacrifice,
like at what level did that sacrifice now bless my families
and create more family time because of that sacrifice,
and so imbalance for a quarter of a year
or for a time period, but that sacrifice in turn
will create an opportunity for me
to be more one-
It's a leverage point.
Yeah, it's a leverage point.
Yeah, yeah.
Well, here's one for you,
and I'm wondering whether you relate to this,
myself being someone who like appreciates suffering
and I feel like I have a capacity for that as well.
What happens with me is
I equate maybe not success,
but whether I've given my all to something
is calibrated in lockstep with how much I've suffered.
So whether it's a book or writing a speech
or preparing for a pod...
Whatever it is, it's like, if I haven't suffered,
I didn't work hard enough on it.
Like I could work harder on it,
I could really go down the rabbit hole on this,
I have to really like feel it
in order to feel like I did a good job
and things outside of endurance sports
don't necessarily work that way, right?
So the challenge that,
like, one of the things I'm trying to learn right now
is can I hold these things a little bit more lightly
and be more in the allowing
rather than in the kind of self-will forcing of it,
because that's my instinct, right?
And that instinct doesn't always drive the best result
in areas that are outside of like endurance sports.
Yeah, I battle with that too.
Like if it...
Back to taking the path of least resistance
with the hard road, sometimes when you accomplish something
if it wasn't hard, if it was easy, you get the feeling-
I could've done better.
I could have done better
that project's not what it should've been,
but sometimes it just is easy and it's okay.
And I think that's what you're saying
you're trying to learn is like it's okay
to not have to suffer through something
and still be an excellent piece or product.
Well sometimes it's better if you get out of the way
and just allow it to be, allow it to express itself
in a more kind of like organic natural way
than to try to force it.
Yeah, everything doesn't have to be harder or a struggle.
It doesn't have to be.
That's the thing, right?
I think people hear some of the times
when we say that as like,
oh, okay, I have to struggle, it has to be hard,
I have to face adversity in order to learn.
No, that's just where learning inside it's peak,
but you can still do things and accomplish things
and it'd be easy and it's a breeze
and it's fun and it's enjoyable, and it's enjoyable.
And so, yeah, there's obviously definitely two sides
of that coin, and I have to learn that as well, too.
It's kind of a hard lesson
'cause it just cuts across like my instincts.
Yeah, we're cutting that same mold.
Are any of your kids into this stuff like are-
Suffering or...
No, just like the multi-sport thing
or are they just on their own trip?
They are on their own trip
and that's one of the things...
One of the biggest goals I set out as a parent
was I am not gonna force my passions,
my dreams on my kids.
I'm gonna allow them to be on their own journey
and I'm gonna help create opportunities for them,
but ultimately I want them to follow their passions.
And,
I would say Quinn and-
As of the last six months.
No, I'd say Quinn and Daisy
have a great baseline for suffering.
Yeah but Quinn only as of the last six months.
Like he's just wanted to be a little kid.
But he showed-
He's got like a YouTube channel now though, right?
Oh yeah, Sheepdog776, man.
Sheepdog776.
What does he do on his channel?
Hard core, trampoline.
He's learning how to do flips-
He's doing back flips all over the time.
But the cool thing is that,
so this is in conjunction in what James is saying,
Quinn has found this passion
and he is continuing to grow in this passion.
So he is continuing to learn new sports.
He's moving to parkour on the ground
and he's doing some inner warrior stuff,
but here's what else is cool, he's filming it,
he's editing it, he's posting it.
He enjoys that part of it.
And it's so cool to see.
So for his birthday, we got him a tripod
'cause he has friends he gets to hold this camera for him.
And it's been really neat to see him
not only do what the sport he loves,
but to continue to learn and grow
in different parts of the sport.
So it's been really neat to see him grow into that
because before he's like,
I just wanna wear a Spiderman costumes
and dress up, right?
Where now he's finally showing some passion for athletics
and he's played lacrosse for years,
but it was 'cause his cousin played,
and so we wanted to hang out with this cousin,
but now he's starting to show a little bit.
And then our daughter, Daisy, that James mentioned,
she's our third daughter, she just turned 15.
She is the most easygoing.
She's just like James,
she's like, I don't care if it's messy,
I don't care if it's clean,
I don't care if my homework is good grades,
bad grades, I don't care
but this second she sets her mind to something
she is unstoppable,
and it is a force to be reckoned with.
The trick is finding the right thing.
So she goes through life,
doing things her way
and then every once in a while she finds something
and she just dives into it.
So that's really cool 'cause that's a lot how James is,
James is so easy going, he's just go with the flow,
he has a play mentality
and he's just like YOLO personality,
loving life.
I'm a procrastinator
at heart.
Like he really is,
but then when he finds that thing
and he turns it on, he turns it on.
I mean, and Lucy, Lucy's just like hardcore all the time.
Lily, she just wants to play and have fun
and she realizes being organized is better for her,
then Dolly, our the daughter's just like,
I just wanna do hair and makeup.
Yeah.
So it's interesting
how it's all different,
but those two are the ones that show kind of the turn on
where it's like from normal
to hardcore.
The mental grip.
Yeah, that switch thing.
I mean, you were talking about nurture versus nature,
perhaps that's a nature thing.
I mean, you are a guy, like when I think of you,
it's like, yeah, your word is your bond.
And you say, you're gonna do this thing
like I know James is gonna fulfill on that promise
or die trying, like whatever's gonna happen.
You care so much about this promise that you make,
whether it's to yourself or to the public
and that becomes like this anchor
that holds you accountable to yourself
in terms of like accomplishing these goals.
Yeah, and it's fun.
It is fun to watch those kids that follow in that
and you can start to see,
but as far as doing what we do,
and none of them have any interests, zero.
We keep trying to pitch like mountain biking.
You did like a big family hike up this mountain
the other day.
We did that,
they love that, it's family time.
Dolly was crazy excited the whole time.
I just love hiking, this is so much fun.
And she's the kind of girl that like,
we have to get her out there and then she realize,
Sunny is this way too.
It's like, I have to get Sunny to go do an activity,
she's very resistant and then she does it,
and it's like, this is the best time I've ever had-
I'm a work-minded person.
I've ever had in my life.
Right.
And so no,
we do stuff as a family.
They're very active and very healthy
and they love to get out and do family stuff like that.
Just not something like triathlon,
maybe golf, independent sport.
I dunno, we'll see, we'll see.
Well, there is no such thing as an individual sport,
as individual as triathlon and multi-sport is,
I mean, this really was a beautiful team effort
and family journey that you guys went on.
It's super inspiring to so many people.
I love you guys a ton,
I appreciate you coming to share today
and maybe we can just end this with a few thoughts
for the person out there
who does struggle with getting off the couch
or just figuring out how to bring that will into execution.
How do you start to show up?
Like what if you've never showed up
or you haven't flex that muscle before
and you're inspired by
what you guys have done and the example that you've set,
like how do you get that person activated?
Yeah, I think the biggest thing is,
is helping them realize
that we started from the very beginning,
same self-doubt, same outside criticism coming in,
same trying to battle that conversation
and just set yourself the smallest goals.
One of the best examples I've ever read
was from the book, Atomic Habits, James Clare,
when he said, okay, you don't go to the gym,
you're 350 pounds, your goal is to go to the gym
for literally five minutes.
When five minutes is up, you have to leave the gym.
And the person on the beginning
of their journey would be like,
I'm not gonna accomplish anything
by going to the gym for five minutes a day.
'Cause the flip side of that is someone says,
okay, I'm gonna go to the gym 90 minutes, six days a week
and they fail every single time, it's inevitable.
It always happens,
nobody that is at the beginning of that journey
can set an expert level goal and accomplish it.
And the whole process or reason for doing that
is because it's a mind, it's a mind deal.
And you now become,
even though you've only gone to the gym for five minutes,
if over the past two weeks,
you've gone to the gym every day for five minutes,
you now can say the words, I'm a gym goer.
Right, I'm the kind of person
who goes to the gym.
I go to the gym,
I go to the gym every single day.
And so my advice to someone who's just starting is,
one, absolutely realize that your journey is worth it,
you're worth showing up on your own journey
and meet yourself where you're at today
and set that expectation, but then set yourself such,
almost a ridiculously achievable goal
so that you can start to gain confidence and momentum.
And once you do that, now push the limits,
now start to go, you can't go from zero to 100.
My journey didn't start off the couch to 100 ironmans.
It started a formal fun run that I struggled through,
that Sunny made fun of me for that put us on this journey,
so ultimately it's her fault that we're here,
but really that's my greatest-
I take credit for it.
You created this whole-
This monster, so that's my advice is,
is meet yourself where you're at today, believe in yourself,
know that you're enough and to just start
and set yourself almost a ridiculously low goal,
to give yourself some confidence and momentum.
I'd say find something hard to do every day.
For some people that hard is-
Brushing your teeth.
Brushing your teeth
or talking to the person
checking you out at the grocery store
or to just leave the house or to make a phone call
that you have been putting off.
But every time I mountain bike, if I'm on an easy stretch,
I intentionally look for like hard rocks and stuff to hit
because I'm like there's no better time to practice
going over those rocks than in this safe zone.
So find hard things to do inside your safe zone,
and just do it one hard thing a day.
Yeah.
One hard thing.
Solid advice, both you guys.
I'm gonna resist the temptation to ask you the question
that I'm sure everybody asks you at the end of these things.
What's next?
You know what it is.
You know what it is, right?
What's next?
I'm not gonna ask you that.
I don't wanna know what's next,
there doesn't have to be a next.
I've got a great answer.
Do you?
I do.
I didn't ask you, either way.
I know, I'm gonna volunteer.
Here, let me handle this.
Hey, James, so what's next?
What's next?
Yes.
So obviously we're in the recovery phase of what we're doing
that is what's right in front of us, what's next,
but I've kind of gone down this rabbit hole of recovery
of biohacking the mind and the body
and all of the incredible tools that are out there,
if you have access to them
to utilize them just with food and just everything.
What's next for me it would be to live a healthy,
sustainable quality of life beyond age 105.
He keeps changing it.
It used to 100.
I know, but then you said,
you said you're gonna live to-
I said I'm gonna live as a widow
'cause I'll make it to 100 but you'll be 105.
I know, so I said 105
'cause there's five years difference,
so I had to adjust it 'cause I wanna be with you.
I got a couple of guys you should talk to
on a couple of books for you to read.
I'm reading Dave Asprey's book right now.
You read David Sinclair's book?
Ah-ah.
You should read that.
This guy, Sergey Young,
he was just on the podcast
has a book that just came out called Growing Young.
Cool, I'm fascinated with all of it
because obviously my whole career
has been breaking my body down
and I'm to the point now where I'm like, okay, I need to-
It's oxidative stress.
I need to build this back up
so that I can hit this goal of what's next
and living to beyond 105, so.
Well, the amazing thing is throughout this whole thing
you really didn't lose any body weight,
like you maintained your weight.
Yeah, in both campaigns.
People ask us all the time
is he on steroids or something?
No, he's just born like that.
No, I just eat a lot of food.
You do, yeah.
I eat so much food.
Is one of the hardest things we did
was eat that amount of food to maintain it.
Yeah, it's been crazy.
You guys are welcome back here anytime.
I love talking to you today.
We love you, Rich.
See you tomorrow.
And you guys
are easy to find.
So people should check out your book, Redefine Impossible.
There's the documentary the Iron Cowboy,
the 50, 50, 50 journey or something.
What is it called?
It's called Iron Cowboy,
currently sits on Amazon Prime.
Right, cool.
And then to follow anything crazy we do,
or what is next is, we've posted everything on Instagram,
so ironcowboyjames,
and then everything can be linked
or found through our website, ironcowboy.com.
Cool, right on.
Sunny, any final words?
Sunnyjolawrence on Instagram.
I'm not very good at posting,
but I've set this new goal
because people keep asking me to post,
people keep requesting and I have to get in the habit.
You have to get out Of your comfort zone.
I know, I know.
Do something hard, Sunny.
Create that new atomic habit.
Be the person who-
That's the plan.
I got you, the problem is this.
I did those closet talks in day 98
and then all of a sudden Instagram won't let me load videos.
So I haven't been able to load any videos.
I can't figure out what's wrong with it,
it's this weird thing,
I've tried deleting the app, tried everything.
So then I got out of the habit
and so I've been getting requests like, please post more.
So I'm doing that, starting the habit, it's happening.
You are a problem solver
and it sounds like a problem that you could probably solve.
Almost sounded like an excuse, this is bad,
we should end this right now.
This is it, this is the new habit,
I'm gonna post more.
All right,
I'm gonna log on Instagram tomorrow and see what's what's.
It's gonna happen, tomorrow?
Okay, good to know I've got a deadline.
I've got to do something today.
(laughing)
All right, you guys, thanks.
Thank you.
Big surprise.
(bright ambient music)